I changed.
I swapped too.
We're just like, oh don't, we're okay, we're live.
We're live.
We're doing it live.
Yeah.
I was late because of mint.
Oh, we literally just had this conversation.
Yeah, exactly.
Well, we had this conversation, but they didn't know that,
you know, they didn't.
Yeah, we're just waiting on Yeah, that's true That's true,
we're late because of Naimu and Snuffy Because they're not
here yet, you know Oh yeah, they're streaming Oh my god, I
can't believe they're not here yet Guys Oh my god Where's
their punctuality?
Yeah, oh my god They're not gonna look good on the
leaderboards That's all I'm gonna say Did you see the
leaderboards that they posted a while ago But like Streamers
punctuality and gap ratio.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
I've been grinding hard.
I'm going to get rank one.
I mean, I'm going to.
Hello.
Hi.
Hey, guys.
I can't believe you guys were late.
I mean, I've been waiting for you guys.
No, he's not even here.
You say you guys.
Oh, yeah.
You know what?
Next time I'm just going to join us this year.
As soon as it hits the time, I'm going to join off the rip
and leak everything.
I'm the worst to leak ourselves.
Wow.
Apparently I've muted you guys too because my audio is set
up.
I haven't done anything on Discord since I was hung out with
you.
Oh no.
Hold on.
Let me fix it.
I was silenced to my friends.
Let me re-add you back.
How did I do that last time?
Oh, is it this?
Can they hear us?
I also need sound people.
They can hear me.
Oh, dang.
I was gonna say.
We're gonna leave.
We're gonna leave everything.
Oh, yeah.
You're spilling stuff.
You were spilling me earlier.
Yeah.
Oh, hey.
someone's birthday today my chat Mr. Brody Bond Happy
birthday Today's my birthday I saw people saying it's
national Big Boob's Day So maybe I can Whoa National what
day?
It's national big boobs day Whoa Whoa It's like a smooth
That's every day for me I don't know But I take off the
sports bra Hey Snuffy Hi Snuffy Hi Snuffy Are you okay
Snuffy Yeah, I was just excited.
Oh, yeah, because she's an exciting day.
We're going to make it, right?
Everybody's favorite.
I actually solo beat the game on the new update.
You did not.
I did it.
Yes, I even showed it on stream.
I showed it on stream.
I did it off stream.
But I, you know how it's so easy when there's no dead
weights on me?
Why didn't we make it?
Why didn't you solo it last time?
No, sorry.
Quick question.
Who is the only one that made it to the top the other time
to play?
Not you and Lymo.
Lymo's the exception here.
Lymo's the exception.
You are great, Lymo.
You're always carrying us and everything.
And I really appreciate it.
Oh, you know, you know, keep going.
Keep going, please.
You're so good.
Sloppy sisters at 99%.
Yeah, 99%.
Yes, because I have my limiters on because I know Lymo is
here.
I don't have to try, you know?
Oh, don't worry.
I got you.
Wait, man, I'm grabbing the screenshot.
I'll prove all of you guys wrong.
A screenshot doesn't mean anything.
I believe you.
I have the stash.
You know, I have the stash that says you solo beat Peek.
Do you have it, Mint?
Actually, I haven't played Peek since the last time Limeo
carried us.
I mean, that was awesome.
I don't think I played Peek since that time either.
This is going to be fun.
oh this is gonna be pretty exciting yeah i haven't played in
a hot minute wait guys guys before wait i mean i'm trying to
find the screenshot i swear to god i showed it on stream
guys my chat my chat was a dream my chat her chat is
currently doctoring it right now yeah yeah my chat's not in
photoshop literally right now i was photoshopping it live
like peaked guys BAM check hangout look at that you oh yeah
we posted it yeah no deaths no deaths hell yeah ggs no free
very nice very nice yeah i look so upset about it because i
had to do it i had to do it alone yeah i haven't played in
so long are there are the new maps in rotation right or are
we going back to like the new maps are on rotation right now
and uh it's gonna be out of rotation by the end of this week
so we got it just in time yeah all right we gotta we gotta
promote it yeah yeah yeah yeah also i recently discovered
that i was talking to my manager about this but i was
partially blind for a almost a year because i didn't realize
uh i was like i'm sorry what
because I didn't realize there were scratches on my glasses
lens because I don't pay attention to that so because my my
eyes were so accustomed to scratches on my lens that I
didn't realize that like they were at it was actually
partially hindering my eyesight before you had your monitors
on i actually i just set my glasses i got a pair of new
glasses but yeah it's like i have like super thin delicate
skin on my nose and I was getting so tilted like when you
when I was wearing them scraping your nose skin I was
getting like friction blisters because I couldn't wear my
contact lenses for like a month and I so I had to wear
glasses every day and I was ending up with blisters so I was
like okay fuck it I'm gonna go buy some really nice premium
glasses I got them they finally arrived scratch on the lens
so it's been six weeks I'm waiting because I had to send
them back and get them redone oh my god I'm the same way
though I can't wear glasses because of Yeah, our skin
delicate skin.
Yeah.
Oh, my sink is too buttery.
People would be like, are you bruised?
But it's just blood under the skin.
We just go.
Oh, my God.
Nose-pitched twinsies.
Yeah.
Wait, why is Snuffy Defin?
Is she okay?
Oh, she hates this conversation.
Yeah, she's like, she's like, she was not interested in this
one.
She's like, guys, they're being so boring.
They're talking about glasses.
Oh my gosh.
I'm not being blind.
I hate corrective vision.
I have no sympathy for the heart of seeing.
So yeah, I finally realized because like I found my last
pair of glasses and I put it on like, whoa, everything is so
much clear right now.
There's no smudge.
By the way, there was a really bad scratch in the middle of
my right eye lens.
So they were like, oh, like there was a really bad one.
So like I put it on and I was like, wow and i put on my
other my newer glasses and i was like oh i see the smudge
now i you were literally playing you were like living life
like like cataract simulator like i was i played turn by the
way i played tournaments with that glasses on very nice well
now you have no excuse yeah now my demons and it's just a
scratch on your lens and everyone else is like what the pop
all right sound team my sound team is everybody's audio okay
i mean we're gonna do like in-game audio later too okay yeah
go to everybody's streams and tell us if we all sound all
right can you come in a chat thank you snuffy do you want to
do a stream together with me do you want to stream together
to do a stream i mean we don't have it but like youtube
actually oh that would be so cool if they did i thought we
are streaming together right now no that's true that's where
we're all here together we're all streaming together but no
this is like the the i hate this fucking thing sometimes
when people like there's also a knock feature where you can
just spontaneously go to someone else's channel and press
the knock button it's like if you should do that at me yeah
no don't you fucking dare.
I swear to God, don't you dare knock on my channel.
I'm not allowed 10 feet in front of Limu's yard.
What did you do in Limu's yard, Stuffy?
I'm going to antagonize her dogs.
I'm barking at him.
I didn't bark at him.
Here you go.
I posted the link in the channel.
You can join.
I'm going to join it, too.
Yeah, I'm going to join it as well.
Dude, if you have a Twitch burner account, come join.
It'll be fun.
Wait, I do.
This will be my first ever Twitch stream.
Oh, my God.
Just on your YouTube stream and go on Twitch.
I'm pushing ghosts.
Wait, I can't join.
I'm joining Session 2.
It says I need to verify my phone number.
It says I'm on here.
Sorry, you look like a bot.
I'm in it too.
Wait, I can chat with you.
Hey, guys.
I have it all muted.
I don't even have any audio on that thing.
Okay, your sound team is telling me to turn you to zero.
That's not my sound team.
Oh my god, are you guys excited, though, about this
announcement?
I am excited.
I get stressed like I'm going to accidentally leak
something.
I mean, to be fair, people might already sort of know the
announcement, though.
How?
Because I quote-tweeted the thing that was it which one was
it like off-car?
Okay, okay, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Okay, not Lime or Lime?
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Lime is actually a real thing.
I was just trying to, oh my god.
I was trying to hand it, but then Lime was like, you know,
oh yeah, we're for the exact thing where it came from.
Just, I was doing a little tease about it and like, oh, yes,
it might have been sort of previewed.
un-retweet it.
Nobody's gonna know.
Nobody's gonna know racing to un-retweet it before anybody
else looks so long.
Wait, I wanna see.
What did you retweet?
You wanna see, no, no, no, look, I'm retweeted.
Also, I will say it was part, it has been in the works for a
while only because it was partially my fault and I take full
blame responsibility for it.
Yeah, that was the reason why it got delayed so long.
What?
It had been like a whole year or something.
and time goes to do it all and i didn't realize it's all
your fault yeah don't worry and we'll announce it in 15 by
might have been me are you still scrolling limo i can hear
you i'm scrolling i can't find it
i haven't just gone boom boom that's literally scrolling and
everything also that's a reminder i need to fix my noise
gate on Discord.
Yeah, that's very weird.
After that, you have a comically large mouse.
Yeah, it's loud.
It's loud.
It's like, boom, boom, boom.
My chat, my chat is tweet, like, messaging the link at me.
It's, well, now everyone's gonna see it.
Oh, my God!
Somebody messaged it to me!
Why did you have to say it and tell our chats about it?
You're kidding.
Wait, I'm gonna go, okay, I'm going to Limu's Twitter.
Loud.
oh no oh no it's all going to hell apparently it's all right
and 10 okay i mean like technically you say what you can
just do it now you can just do it now i mean now that the
surprise is sloppy sisters you guys just let it go we are
true true sloppy announcement yeah sloppy from top to bottom
inside nl Oh, yeah, but we also found out I'm in April.
Did I find it yet or no, I deleted it.
Oh, no, you didn't Oh, you did it.
It's gone.
Oh, yeah.
We found out lime was playing the news.
Were you playing on stream the Star Wars game?
Yes.
Yeah.
I just named my first chat member.
I'll make you guys Yeah, you gotta make you make your first
chat member over us.
Where are you?
Because like they did a rap And I felt that.
Oh, okay, that's sweet, but still.
A raffle.
Yeah.
What is XCOM?
I don't even know.
Is that like... I don't know either.
It's a tactical.
It's like a tactics game, basically.
It's like Rimworld or whatever?
No, no.
I do like Rimworld.
It's like this other game that's unrelated.
That's the only other time that I know people make
characters for people and stuff.
I don't know.
No, so XCOM is basically like, yeah, it's a tactical show.
shooter it's it's turn based and have you ever seen the
jokes where people are like 95 chance to hit and then I
missed that's that's from xcom where it's like you
everyone's got like percentage chances to actually like fire
like hit with a gun and then she can make fun of the game
and she can kill us I mean it's fallout as well but it's
also it's xcom when you think about xcom yeah when he said
xcom I thought you were talking about like a convention like
it sounds like back in like a g4 It sounds like a gaming
convention.
It's like the real XCOM.
XCOM does it sound like a gaming convention?
That sounds like a...
XCOM is back, guys.
It does.
I'm at, you guys, I'm here at XCOM.
We're going to check out my game.
Wait, what was the...
We're going to check out the ladies' video game.
Who's the guy's name that does the presentation for the game
awards?
Jeff.
Yeah, Jeff is there.
Jeff Keely.
Respect his name.
Yeah.
See, I thought XCOM to me sounds kind of like a, like a sex
con or something.
So it's just like...
Yeah.
Julia XCOM, get it now.
I thought it was like an X-Men convention.
X-X-X-X!
It's like XCOM.
Those are the mods for the game.
What was the X-Men quote?
The X-Men...
I'm the X-Men.
The X-Men quote, famous movie lines.
The famous, famous X-Men quote, I am the X-Men.
Yeah, to me, my X-Men.
That one, to me, my X-Men.
Oh, I was gonna say, is it to me, my X-Men?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's basically exactly what I said, so I don't even feel
like that was far off anymore.
Why are you talking about X-Men?
I don't, I don't know.
I thought you were gonna say something really weird.
Like, what's that X-Men quote?
Because we were talking about X-Men.
talking about X-rated conventions, I was like, like, what,
X-Men, I'm coming kind of thing?
I don't know what that's like.
Stop coming, X-Men.
I'm coming, X-Men.
My favorite Charles Xavier quote.
Remember when Charles Xavier...
Yeah, Charles Xavier rolls in with his wheelchair.
He's like, I'm coming, X-Men.
I mean, old school Charles Xavier was kind of a dirty
bastard so he might have been okay have you heard of the
Holocaust beam have you I'm sorry what does that have to do
with XXXCOM is my favorite fun okay it might not be a fun
fact but it's oh yeah it's hilarious it's my favorite fact
right to turn you down to zero.
Okay.
My chat knows a lot about the Holocaust theme.
But, because I always, so I somehow bring it up, like, every
couple of weeks or so.
What's wrong with you?
No, because there's context.
That sounds like our context.
But, like, because people would talk about Charles Xavier,
and I was like, that guy's not a good man.
Because at one point, Um, it's canon, by the way, in the
X-Men universe.
So, like, the way for Charles Xavier to disarm Magneto,
because Magneto's a Holocaust survivor, he would do the
Holocaust theme, where he would, like, make Magneto, like,
remember the trauma of living through the Holocaust.
So that he would, yeah, so that's, yeah.
I mean, yeah, so essentially it's actually PTSD beam, but,
you know, the Holocaust beam.
Yeah, but it's, like, specifically the Holocaust.
It's, it's, it's, like, actually animated that scene in TV
shows, too.
Dude, I love old comics because they're all fucking like
just unhinged like that one comic where it was like, what if
Spider-Man?
And then it's like, yeah, what if there was a world in which
Spider-Man, because he's got radioactive spider blood, also
had radioactive spider cum.
And he accidentally got married Jane Cancer or something.
Oh, like, yeah, I want to see it, but like...
My favorite is Spiders Man, which is...
Oh, I love that too.
Spider-Man wasn't a man.
It wasn't a bunch of spiders.
It's because, you know, the lore behind that?
It's basically Peter Parker got dropped in the vat of
spiders and they ate him alive.
And then all the spiders consumed, like, Peter's essence.
And then they were, like, basically the soul of Peter
Parker.
And they're like, oh, so that's why they become...
Yeah, so they became, like, the collective.
So I'm just going to believe you on all of this.
Oh, yeah, here's the video of the exact scene where he does,
like, the beam into Magneto.
Oh, my God.
comic thing I know is just when they're just like a wooden
gun like that's the only thing I remember from the old
comics you've never seen the wooden gun kit like the what
okay because Magneto right he's like magnate so like they
beat him one day in the like old cartoon version because he
pulls out a gun and he's like you fool I'm gonna mind
control your gun and shoot you and he's just like do it bro
do it and he tries and it doesn't work so he has like a
mental breakdown being like Why can't I control your gun?
What's wrong with me?
And he's just like, got him, bro.
It's actually a wooden gun, L.
And then he, like, arrested him.
Like, he literally went crazy.
He's like, why can I do this?
Wooden bullets.
Am I losing my powers?
Like, that shit is, like, what's going on?
And he just, it's just one of those moments where he says it
really silly.
And he's just like, a wooden gun?
My greatest weakness.
What?
What about Fantastic Four?
Oh, man.
I don't know.
I'm feeling bad for Magneto.
Bro, that guy committed genocide.
What do you mean you feel bad?
You feel bad for a man who committed war crimes.
That's fucked up, man.
That's actually fucked up.
I actually don't know what he's done.
All I know is that he survived the Holocaust.
It's supposed to be interesting because, you know, he
obviously survives the Holocaust, but then he also decides
that, you know, mutants are superior to humans.
And then it's like, well, wait a sec, bro.
He nuts in your hypocrisy here, a little bit, man.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
In terms of, like, stupid comic book panels, I really like
the Spider-Man one, where he, like, goes against that guy
that's a dinosaur, and he's, like, able to rewrite, like,
genetic code.
Oh, I love that.
And Spider-Man's, like, yeah, Spider-Man's like, yo, with
your science, you could, like, cure cancer.
And then the dinosaur man's like, I don't want to cure
cancer.
I want to turn people into dinosaurs.
Because it's, it's coarse.
Yeah.
He is so valid.
I get it.
Yeah, dinosaurs can't get cancer.
Well, we don't know that, but like...
Inadvertently.
Yeah, so technically, like, you get to be, like, 20 feet
tall, no cancer, and a dinosaur.
Hell yeah.
That guy did nothing wrong.
I say that now.
Yeah.
Put it on the record.
It's the same as, like, when they had that...
I showed you the panel.
The new Spider-Man movie, where...
Well, I'm sorry.
The most recent Spider-Man...
Second to most...
recent Spider-Man movie where they bring the lizard back and
they bullied his character down to wouldn't you like to be a
lizard and that's kind of just what he's like his whole
thing is that and then someone's like let me guess you'd fix
this by making us into lizards and he's like exactly yeah
but you can regenerate limbs what did you want that i need
to watch more spider-man spider-man is great he's got some
ridiculous okay but like the whole thing about spider-man is
just that he's like the most bullyable character in the
entire marvel universe because like the Well, not hate him,
hate him, but they make it so that he suffers.
Like he, in all his suffering, yeah.
They believe that Peter Parker's suffering is part of his
character, so they often just find ways to, like, reset the
status quo and make his life suck.
Like, so it's actually really funny because for a while the
Spider-Man comic book audience was super pissed because they
decided that in order to continue keeping Mary Jane and
Peter Parker apart, like, because they do all sorts of
things to make sure he can't be happy, one of which being
they erased his whole marriage to save a 90-year-old woman.
But anyway, in order to keep them apart, they decided that
they were going to insert this guy.
I can't remember what his name is.
It was something awful like Todd.
And it basically became the spider or Paul.
Todd did nothing wrong.
It became the Spider-Man cuck saga.
And he was just like, well, Mary Jane, I think Paul is so
good for you.
And she's like, do you want to come over for dinner with
Paul and I?
And it's like, no.
Oh my god.
Damn you, Paul.
Have you seen the Rest in Peace My Granny?
She got blew up by a bazooka.
Wait, what?
It's all a bunch of like clips of...
So it's a song where it goes, Rest in Peace My Granny.
She got blew up by a bazooka.
And it's all clips of the aunt being blown up.
Where did this come from?
Is this also related to Spider-Man?
I love comic books, man.
Kaboom, ka plow.
We had no explanation.
Yeah, we have no explanation.
Just like, hey guys, I'm related to the Spotted Man topic.
It's about his aunt.
No, that is the aunt.
It just meant somebody's random .
Oh.
I was trying to do a smooth segue.
That was not fair.
announcement yeah that's the oh yeah that's the segue to the
announcement but the god fucking blowing up someone um one
of my mods linked it is this the video oh what oh it's the
rest in peace my granny she got hit by a bazooka oh oh yeah
yeah yeah it's the scene from the spider-man where the like
the green goblin is like entries on her when she's praying
at the bed and then and then she's like finished your prayer
which spider-man which spider-man kobe mcguire spiders man
here Hey, Spider's Man is a completely different guy,
please.
And then they'll sometimes make, like, remixes where it's,
like, different songs.
They'll be like, Rest in peace, my granny.
She got hit by a bazooka kaboomka plow.
R-I-P.
Oh, man.
Okay, anyway, with that, we shall segue into the
announcement.
All this transition definitely related to the announcement.
So, kaboom, kaboom, kaboo.
I blew up my art with a bazooka.
Well, okay, this has been in the works for a while.
Only, I take partial blame.
I'll, I'll explain later how it was sort of my fault that
this got delayed for a while.
I'm curious how that happened, because I don't even know.
Yeah.
It's sort of my fault.
Keep hedging, keep hedging.
It's sort of my fault, but I have a reasonable explanation
for this.
I have, I might not have been replying back on time, but I
also have another reason for it.
Okay.
I have an explanation for my explanation.
I have an explanation for my explanation, though.
All right, do we all have the video?
Yeah.
Give me two seconds.
Can you give me the URL again, please?
Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'll give you guys the link.
first you guys are late yeah of course the people that are
late don't have the video how would you how do you know how
to use youtube man i don't know how to use youtube oh it's
in the google drive what do you mean it's in the google
donkey yeah i didn't know i had to have it i thought i was
putting it up i thought i was what i thought i was watching
it on youtube which i mean oh wait we could do that too yeah
yeah yeah i was just gonna watch your youtube video we're
gonna show it on stream well i was gonna show it on yeah i
was gonna show okay wait wait i You have the link, right?
I was going to show you a YouTube video once.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Do you guys have the link ready?
No.
The link to your YouTube video?
Min and I are showing...
Okay, wait.
We're so...
I don't know how to use YouTube, man.
I don't know how to use YouTube.
We are professionals.
Listen, listen, I stream on Twitch.
All right.
Listen, we are the sloppy...
You're getting what the name says.
Like, we are the sloppy sisters.
You should not be surprised with what's happening.
So wait wait wait am I just plugging the video into my
audience or am I using your YouTube?
I'm giving you the YouTube link.
Okay.
Oh your thumbnails are so cute.
Oh the art.
I don't do thumbnails because you don't need them on Twitch.
Oh yeah.
All right.
All right here's the YouTube link.
Wait wait wait wait what about?
Oh okay.
Okay I just showed the video.
I'll do a countdown.
Oh we're doing a countdown.
Is the video already live?
Should I just like we count down and we all play?
Yeah yeah and then we all play.
Do we want to talk while the video is playing?
playing I don't know do we Lymu showed it on stream Lymu
showed it on stream thank you Lymu showed it on stream
already I'm really slow please please my brain 5 4 are we
talking while we're doing this No, I would just not because
my brain starting to like explore.
We don't mute it.
We mute it up when we show the video.
We're going to mute.
I'm just not going to say anything.
Okay, I won't say anything.
Okay.
You count us in, mint.
Yeah, then you count us in.
Me?
Oh my god.
Yeah, because you will try to count down the last three
times.
You are counting down.
Why are you surprised, mint?
All right, I got this.
99 98 97 96 95 just let her keep going she'll tire herself
out 93 just let her let her keep going and let her live with
her mistakes 90.
no no let her keep going 86 85 84 83 82 81 80.
you think i'm gonna get tired you think i don't make sure
yes keep counting this is you like he could spend you made
what was i at you were at 80 80 you're at 80 80 80 87 no
don't put it all the way up there it's five four five i'm at
five no no you're at 70 you're at 70.
you're at 70.
trying to auto play ads and i can't snooze she chose this 75
wait that 76 77 75 75 74 73 72 71 70 nice 68 67 you guys are
distracting oh you're the one that started at 100 65 you're
64 63 62 61 60 59 58 57 56 55 54 53
52 51 what is there something funny I don't remember what
came after 51 I was concerned oh I was doing a pregnant
pause what is a pregnant pause do you want to get to the
number zero no no no keep going keep going 50 I'm going to
scroll Twitter 48
47, 46, 45, 44, 43, 42, 41.
Wait, you didn't do 43.
Wait, 43.
Wait, I'll start back at 50.
50, I think you, like, I lost count where we are.
You should start back at 100 at this point.
48, 47, 46, 45, 44, 43, 45.
42, 41, 40, 39, we're almost there guys.
39, 38, 37, 36, 35, 34, 33, 32, 31, what is it?
It's crazy that it's like, it's crazy that this minute and a
half countdown has taken three minutes.
I'm not sure how you fucking meant.
29, 28, 27, 26, 25.
25, 24, 23, 22, 21, 20.
Yeah!
We're almost there!
17, 16, 15, 14, 13, 12, 11, 10.
Let me tell you about nine, eight, seven, six, five, a four,
a three, a two, one, a three, two, one, Yo!
I plus play, fuck you!
Wait, oh I did the right thing.
Maybe, oh my god, the video's playing.
The countdown was like three and a half times fucking longer
than the video!
You had three and a half the screen!
What do you mean?
I wasn't looking at my...
Surprise!
Stoppies University!
Yay!
So we have a very special merch collaboration with Gina
Draws!
As the Stoppies Sisters!
Oh my god, it's live already.
It's live already.
Yeah, it's live already.
Oh, I played the wrong video.
Oh my god, the wrong fucking one video did you play?
Wait, guys, can we do it again?
Okay.
the top went to the top no wait wait i downloaded the wrong
one i downloaded the model i just i just pushed i if you
were mocking me about having to get the youtube link there
was a
i got
i got a show i need to show my chat what was on your fucking
stream wait did you just watch the spider-man no she watched
what was the model Oh yeah, and then I play the right video
for you right now.
Alright, you play the right video, I'll play the one that
Mint played, alright?
Alright, I was doing a countdown from the top Mint.
Oh no, I'm already playing it.
Oh you already played, okay, I'll play it too.
Okay, I'm not going to play it.
I'm just gonna look at the screen shot of you in the wrong
panel.
I'm confused, I'm confused now.
She played the one and you see the Google Drive with the
models, the like modeling and all of the stuff?
That's the one that she played.
versus the welcome to sloppy university you know video
montage okay let me load that up did we all play a separate
video i'm starting to get concerned now no i played the one
on the youtube premiere so presumably that's the right one
we all did the right thing except for mint when she was when
she had three minute countdown i'm gonna go plug in the
other video and deafen my chat because obs like auto plays
this well actually wait hold on all right i'll play Yeah, I
did that.
Yeah, you guys want to play it a third time, you know, just
to have it in their heads, you know?
I'm gonna play the new video and deafen myself.
She played a thirst trap.
How do I turn it down?
Oh my gosh.
Are you guys ready for a third time of the video?
Let me turn it down.
Everybody's asking if you could put a dinosaur image in
front of it because it's much more easier to pay attention.
It's much more immersive.
It's like a subway service, you know?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
do something else too guys yeah yeah yeah yeah it wouldn't
let me it wouldn't let me not auto play the video so it just
started at like a million decibels i didn't even check how
loud it was i hope you do closest you're trying this is fun
this is fun it would have started screaming if it was bad it
all looks so pretty it all looks so pretty i'm like putting
the pictures i'm just I'm just looping it.
Oh, and I just hid myself with a rip.
Already moved to bottom.
There we go.
We're back.
All right, here's the link to the video.
I assume my manager will unlist the video now.
Manager.
Oh, man.
Wow, I'm super glad that this is possibly the most fucked up
announcement I've ever been a part of.
That won't have any other way for us.
Happy sister announcement.
Yay!
I don't know what it is about the link that you said,
Bidoki, but I'm like walled from it.
I cannot touch it.
We can't touch it.
Access what?
I want to get my, I want to get the pictures.
Oh, the pictures?
Go to the main site?
Oh, wait, do you mean the Google Doc?
I'll just send you the pictures.
The Google Doc.
I can't download them.
They're not downloading them.
No, you can.
you just right-click the no it won't let me i'm gonna put
this on my chat let me let me just snafy i'm gonna send you
your own images okay i have just my own but i wanted to put
up the whole collection oh yeah yeah i have the whole thing
yeah let's oh yeah i have it too yeah everyone accepts novi
has it let me just always say they're all so good snuffy not
allowed all right let me let me turn off this okay now i did
it first no i did it first it's on my No, it's on my screen
first.
Okay, look at this.
Let me, let me, let me You better use mine.
You better use mine, Snoopy.
Who's up first?
Who's up?
Me or Min?
Who's the first person posted it?
Who's the first person?
It's me.
Oh, let's have a look.
Let me, let me, let me tie break here.
Give me a second.
Look, see?
On my screen, Min posted first.
Yes!
Because you're close, you're European.
So like, mine's further away from you.
PST you bitch shut up I'm further away.
I'm further away.
How I'm in Canada What checkmate.
I'm in Canada.
I automatically am further away.
You're literally a closer relative Okay, okay, I just want
to get involved in the race so I just DM Snoopy directly Who
do you see first who do you see first uploaded?
I don't I don't want to separate this family
It's not taking, it's not taking aside if it's just the
truth.
I'm showing on my chat the proof that I posted first.
Nah, my post in my chat, believe me.
This is what mine looks like.
Now, nobody be mad.
Yes!
It's ping.
It's because she's closer.
It's discrimination.
It looks like you're going to need a new PC update.
Yeah.
No, it's discrimination towards Canadians.
fiber in her like you were just a skill issue for real but
yes we have okay to put to segue yes we have a new apparel
collection yes it's a sloppy sister ex-gina draws collection
and pretty exciting because it's university themed
university who's class are you gonna join look how cute they
all are you guys yeah with like varsity jackets i graduated
school but i dropped out doesn't it look like i did but then
you can look like you can wear these as if you're still
there you know relive your relive the glory days type deal
oh god no i love the hat i know that's just like it's all oh
yeah my the hat is the hat is super cute i love it yeah i
have like caught Okay, yeah, I had, like, the original
concept of the hat, too.
Oh, what?
Oh, what's the original?
It's where I was, like, a little bunch of...
I was a cat.
You were a cat?
Yeah, originally it was a cat face, and then I was like, oh,
I'm a bird, so I feel like...
I should be, like, bird instead of a cat for the hat.
Why do you have cat ears, then?
What do you mean, I don't have cat ears?
You have to do, sometimes.
Oh, I know.
Yeah, that's when I'm a cat.
That's when I am a cat, when I'm a kitty.
Then why can't you be a cat?
Because I'm not Doki right now, Doki Bird.
It's not a mistaken identity.
Sorry, I got to play the wrong video.
Years on the back of the, on the, is this like when you all
started streaming or something?
Like, I don't mind when I started YouTubing, yeah.
Oh, yeah, mine does.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, okay.
So, this is my collection.
That's when I started, too, yeah.
It's so pretty.
I love it.
I love the shirt.
It's available for pre-order now.
Yeah.
If they tickle your fancy, please, please feel free.
I like it because especially the cardigan, I feel like you
could wear that and it's not just like for me personally, I
like it when like there's like an option between stuff
that's like pretty VTuber coded and stuff that's like not
VTuber coded because then I can wear the not VTuber.
Well, not mine.
Mine literally just says dokeybird.
Doesn't yours have lots of pictures of like birds on it?
It's just so cute.
It's got like ducks on it.
It's super cute.
Ducks?
No, no, no, no.
What is it?
Ducks, everybody.
Her name is Doki Bird.
That's a flippin' duck.
They call it Doki's called Ducks.
I'm still calling it the Doki's community is called Ducks.
My favorite, my favorite community name, Ducks.
Yeah.
I like this shirt too.
The shirt's really fun.
Yeah, I think my favorite are this, the hat and the shirt.
shirt only because like I love the color scheme of the shirt
and the fact that it's like you know our origin story yeah
yeah yeah it's so cute it's so cute I love how each of our
cardigans and our jackets are like unique in its own way
with our little yeah it's not just like color swaps I like
that well they gave us at least they gave me like a
bajillion oh yeah I have the I sort of maybe the reason why
I was so delayed was because I was like I need more concepts
I did you like enter horrific choice paralysis as well no
it's just like so good though it was hard like everything
she takes I'm just like yes wait no yes I mean yes like that
team yes for me the hardest part was because like I share
colors with a lot of you guys too so um so I had like
original I don't know if I saw the original concept I'm
showing it on stream right now but the My jacket was what
had mint colors on it.
So then so now I was just like, oh.
Yeah, let me show these.
Yeah, so I was like, yeah, originally I was just like, oh, I
don't I want me to have like another different color jacket
only because I felt like I felt like I want each of us to be
like different in a way.
The color schemes.
I like what you went with, but I also like the concept.
Like either is really good.
I think I'm afraid if I show my chat, they're going to be
like, I know, right?
Yeah, I don't like showing chat my options because no
personal preference is a thing and then I start getting like
crippling self-doubt because then they'll be like, oh, but I
like the other one better.
It's like, no, don't do that.
Oh, every time.
Every time.
Yeah.
Can you bring it?
Can you bring the concept, actually?
Yeah, yeah.
It's like I need the concept.
Shut up.
Oh, yeah.
I did my tweet earlier, so let me tweet as well.
Hell yeah.
Yeah.
Now you can, you can resurrect your old off guy tweet.
you can retweet what was it what was the off guy tweet it
was it was it was literally so jana had like uh at the booth
it it just had like you know the the little pictures of us
in like the actual chibbies like oh yeah yeah actually i
retweeted that university and i retweeted it because it was
it was like openly at all of kai so like okay it's okay to
repeat that if you know you know yeah you know you know
don't get i did i mean like i know conceptually it was kind
of just like a like an idea but i did i did think it was
cool you had like wings on your yeah i okay so i had the
original cardigan that was one of the other cardigans that i
was like like debating on but then like we i brought the
doke like the the dokey council in the council a meeting of
the dokey judges i brought the council in and then everybody
voted for the the one that's out now because i i was like
debating for the longest time I am about whether or not
because we even had it manufactured already like the sample
done oh yeah this one's so cute but okay but like the thing
was the the what's it called the ribbon did not work well in
like ira yeah this one looks like so for everyone can feel
i'll show it on stream this is this was the yeah this was
the original cardin that we might have be honest almost
released but then i was just like i don't know about the
ribbon and we were trying to make it worse but it didn't it
was not for my dumb brain you cut this is it's kind of
giving like fred from yeah yeah no that was the intent no
that was the intent but it just didn't work out in real life
i have to go i have to go look at your this is oh my god
you're funneling us all to your your youtube channel i see
how this is oh actually no i posted no i posted I can see
the intent here.
Yeah, the intent was there.
Yeah, yeah, I can see the intent.
So this was the concept art.
Yeah, so this is why it took so long, guys.
This was sort of the reason why, also, because it was like,
we try to figure out what to do with the cardigan.
And I felt so bad.
Like, shout out to Gina for putting up with me because I was
like, oh, no, Gina.
I was just like, she's just...
She's wonderful.
She's very sweet.
She put up with me and be like, oh, no, Gina.
I don't know.
Maybe we should move it.
a different direction while we already got the sample let's
do let's go back to the basics let's scrap the whole thing
i'm so sorry gina and i think maybe we go back to the other
cardigan design i just i don't know yeah i like how um
dokey's and i is uh like uh what do they call them the the
jackets have hoodies on ours yeah i mean we have like a
letterman jacket yeah well i went i went for a varsity
because of the it being like you know um yeah the the
university thing and also because like yeah because i didn't
have an option to do a varsity before and i've had kind of
hoodies in the past not exactly the same as this and i was
like you know what i'll do something a little bit different
we'll see how it goes yeah my hoodie origin was sort of like
dark uh dark blue but that changed into yellow because i was
like oh i feel like we should add some yellow in there you
know you're literally like yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm literally
yellow your major color yeah what's it you say like um dark
blue like what no it's because like i i didn't want it to be
all yellow you know that's the thing yeah yellow is yellow
is a lot for like a main color i sometimes have the same
problem with my colors because like like it's it's like all
green is is like pretty pretty what's wrong with all green
nothing wrong with all green but occasionally it's just like
sometimes people are like oh that's that's a lot of green
and it's like yeah it's a lot of green what if like is that
a problem so is the grass yeah my only the issue why i
didn't want all yellows because the dragoons are also yellow
on the varsity jacket so i felt like always gonna be weird
if it's like yellow on yellow on the jacket so because we
really have yellow on yellow well well at that point we
weren't going to do yellow on yellow for the cardigan but
then i was like i don't know we should do yellow on yellow i
don't know so i was very like oh Gina I don't know I'm sorry
Gina I just don't know oh my god you're like so you're like
a despair yeah I was like a funny story to tell I was just
like Gina you're incredible maybe lighten it up a little bit
that's maybe a little bit lighter blue no I think my main
thing was just like color balancing on the hoodie and that's
it pretty much like it was literally just like Oh, yeah, I
want to make sure there's some pink in there.
The little gradient one you have is so cute.
Oh, yeah, I love that, too.
You have, like, the little lime pocket that's so cute.
I love all the little motifs or whatever.
Yeah, I like it all feels like very much us, each hoodie and
jacket.
It all feels very, like, accurate to us, which makes me
really happy.
Yeah, oh, yeah, and Miss Cardigan, too.
It looks like just like her one of her outfits, too, her new
outfits.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah, I got that too.
I was like, it kind of, well, I wanted the Seifuku.
Like, she proposed the Seifuku, and I was like, Seifuku
cardigan, that's literally me.
So, you can match.
Oh, my God.
We can all match, guys.
I love stuff.
He's cardigan, too, of your, you're the night sky for the
clouds and everything.
Oh, I know.
Oh, my God.
It's so freaking pretty, guys.
I'm, like, I love mine so much.
It's hard because it's obviously so perfectly my aesthetic,
so I'm 나-yeah, as it is, like, pertinent.
It's okay to be biased and, like, yours best, snuffy.
It's fine.
But I like them all.
I just, mine makes me kick my feet because it's me.
It's like one of those things where it's like, oh, I'm gonna
wear these myself because, you know, and who cares if it
looks a bit narcissistic?
It's perfect for me.
Yuki, do you know if they are made to order or if there's,
like, a, because it's pretty nice, It's pre-orders.
But I know Gina's going to be bringing them to conventions
as well.
Oh, okay.
So, like, there'll be extras.
So, there'll be extras for her to bring around for
conventions and stuff.
But obviously, it's like, you know, it's better to pre-order
than to wait until the last minute.
I don't know if Gina's around right now.
But my child wanted to know if the bags were laptop size.
Somebody wants to know.
Gina, are the bags laptop size?
I think they're kind of modeled after the Japanese school
bag.
bag size but that doesn't really help yeah it would probably
fit like a small one yeah the site might have the the
measurements on it yeah i'm going to look at the
measurements i do i'm gonna look at the model main bag
dimension 15.7 by 10 by 4.7 which is an inches and then
centimeters 40 by 25 by 12.
i don't know a lot of numbers i don't know when i started
hearing all those numbers you heard Like, I don't work in,
like, 3D spaces.
Oh, someone in my chat says it says it has a laptop
compartment.
Oh, oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It does.
There you go.
It fits her MacBook Pro.
That's what Gina says.
Okay.
I was going to say, probably good MacBook size.
Yeah.
Look at all the little bags.
Oh, yeah.
There's also a reason why I didn't make it the Varsity Jacky
yellow.
It's because I did another collaboration with Gina already.
And one of the jackets was yellow.
So that was just like, oh, it should be a different color.
just because I already have a yellow sweater, like a yellow
jacket with Gina already.
That's why I also didn't pick yellow for the main varsity
jacket.
I have to quickly go to the bath game.
I've been live for like four hours already.
I need to be.
I'll be right back.
I just can't see if I'm looking at them.
I'm just scrolling at it.
I just, we haven't talked about the bags, but like, I love
how Minta's like the little chocolate and Mimer's got like
all the colors and stuff.
Oh, I have the, like a little bit of a, like a...
They have little like past cases too on them.
They're so cute.
I didn't see that.
Yeah, and it has, like, lining.
Yeah, my bag inside has stars inside.
For my bag.
Cute.
Also, I can find that's where our Discord server logo is,
like, literally the collaboration logo.
It is.
It is, like, the university logo.
Yeah, it's the university logo.
I can pull it up on this.
It's so tiny.
Do we have, like, a resolution?
Yeah, I have a concept art of it.
I'll send it.
Uh, the logo of it.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's a concept art.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
I remember this.
This was a year ago.
I'm so sorry.
It was literally like a year ago.
I'm so sorry, everybody.
I'm not.
It was my bad.
I'm so sorry.
I went through a lot of concepts, guys.
I'm so, I'll show some of the concepts to it.
I like it, though.
You know, I really like how much you like, I don't know,
keep in mind.
for even simple decisions I feel like sometimes I don't have
enough like push back I'm just like I wanted us because I
wanted us to also be like each of us is unique too so I felt
like I think my designs are hardest because like I have like
different colors from each of you guys except for green I
have so I'm like different colors from each of you guys so I
just wanted I was like oh I don't wanted to be too similar
to you guys as well so it's like each like my mind is like
as it's actually like a different colored palette versus
everybody else so that was like so difficult because i was
like oh do i want my old retro dokey color scheme or do i
want to use like black colors or like from the jacket and
stuff like that oh true true i worked with gina a bit
because i think even a year ago when it started i was in
between my designs yeah it kind of like encapsulates like
versions of it which i really like the punk version and the
like star version now yeah yeah it's cute i love it buy it
now everyone now we get to finally reveal it oh i can't wait
to see everybody at it everyone's gonna rep it at con oh my
god true looks so good oh yeah here's like i'm sure i don't
mind showing concepts to to my chat but i'll show you guys
the other sweater designs that i was like i was like so
stuck in between so many designs before we finalized.
Oh, yeah.
Also, the reason why we didn't settle, we didn't end up with
the, um, the other one, the one with the wings was because,
like, um, all the guys were like, I don't want to wear this.
They're like, in the council, in the council, the council,
the guys are like, I sort of want to wear the other one.
And I was like, oh, okay.
Well, I chose it.
I chose my cardigan.
like uh the mind will wear it and they will like it yes
here's my concept guys here i'll post or on the screen i
didn't really change so much though i i there was like a few
things that i was like oh could you like add motifs or
something like like i wanted hello hi welcome back i was
like i want the ribbon or something like more motifs since
everybody else had three motifs yeah yeah yeah i didn't
change so much that's why i was thinking about the the
ribbon on my but it did not look well in real life i wish it
would work out but it didn't work out do you do you do the
thing that i do where every time an artist gives you any
level of choice you just start messaging people desperately
like help yes yes i go i go to every friend yeah i go to a
friend and i i have a voice for it actually where i go i am
once again asking for your opinion that's literally what i
say to everybody everybody seems to have a couch yeah i have
a council too i was just like i have i have a council i'm
just like please assist me i don't know what what do you
prefer my council of dragons but just sometimes i was like
the council's wrong and then i just made a entire decision
and go i did that the other day for something like for for a
different thing people were like i think this one and i was
like i i totally consider your opinion valid however no and
then you just pick something sometimes you have to ask
somebody though to know what your true feelings are you know
if you ask someone and they're like no but in your heart
you're like oh wait i wanted them to say yes and validate me
yeah yeah because you you kind of realize it's like wait you
want that one but i don't and then you realize oh yeah I
have a screenshot of the council.
It was literally, the votes were literally zero to five.
Like, oh my gosh.
And then I was just like, that's not for which one.
For the cardigan from the white one and the yellow one.
It was zero to five.
Wow.
So that's like, in the picture you just posted, it was zero
to, it's like a zero to five on that.
Yeah, I'll show you guys the screenshot.
I found it.
It was this.
Oh, I like the tie, though.
These are so cute compared to each other.
Because I had to pick one, so I was just like, well, they're
going to be the ones buying it.
So I was just like, well, like...
No, I think you went with a good choice.
Well, yeah, wait.
The one doesn't even count.
That was just, like, as a temporary.
So literally nobody...
No, please.
Fred, you just Scooby-Doo, Scooby-Doo.
Scooby-Doo.
Nobody likes Freddy.
Sorry, I'm like popping open a box of Timbits.
Oh, there's only the custard ones left.
This is sad times.
That's true.
Someone said that like the yellow cardigan would remain
cleaner longer because it's harder to get it dirty.
That's true.
Especially white yarn, too, in general.
That gets dirty real quick.
I feel like it gets dirty.
And then also when anything starts like, you know when it
kind of like...
clothing like that starts getting like bobbles or anything
yeah i feel like it looks worse on white than any other
color for whatever reason bobbles you know just what you
know like on knitwear where like on sweaters and things like
that you know when it starts getting little like yeah little
like little spheres on it i don't have to like trim them off
yeah yeah yeah yeah the pilling hair remover for that
pilling yeah yeah pilling yeah my voice is apparently going
i'm like we're Wait, why didn't you be at the same time?
No, because then we have to continue the conversation, you
know?
We have to return at the same time?
Wait, wait, wait.
Last played November 8th, 2025.
Oh, I'm so flunked.
I was just looking at the peak thing.
Wait, where does that say that?
Well, when you look at peak.
If on Steam, it tells you when the last game played.
I got it said on the game.
August 19th.
That's when I solo beat peak, by the way.
That's the date.
Remember that.
That's the last time you played?
That's the last time.
will actually be much more keyed in than me okay i will say
the the last area is fucked it's actually really up and we
won't know or no it's no it's okay so there's there's two
new areas called the gloom and the fortress i won't spoil it
for you but i will say we struggled on the volcano we're
gonna struggle even harder in the fortress it's a good thing
we didn't go with your idea which was we beat peak and then
we do the announcement.
We can get a celebration.
I expected Lyman to carry us like last time.
You know, I expected Lyman to like clutch it out.
And she always, she always clutches it out in the end.
You know, I have very hard expectations on it.
Can't imagine the pressure, though?
It's like, no pressure.
No pressure, by the way.
But if you don't reach the peak, we can't announce.
Yeah, we will not announce this collaboration if you don't
reach the end.
No pressure or anything But it all relies on you Yeah Oh man
But we've been an amazing celebration You know It'd be so
hype And we'd be like It would have been very cool I'm sorry
for not having faith Yeah you just didn't Believe in
yourself Hard enough line We're like we believe in you
Believe in myself Oh no I climbed pink And all I got was
this dang cardigan I'm going in dang cardigan And I'll It
all and a great reward to me.
I got to have this cardigan.
Yeah.
Yeah, but it doesn't have wings on it.
So, like...
I mean, we still have a sample.
Like, I just had to send that one sample.
Would you wear it, though?
Would you wear it?
Oh, maybe around my maid cafe, maybe.
All right, all right.
All right, Gina, do you hear that?
Send that sample over.
Yeah, how long is the pre-order up for?
I should say, right?
It says on the site.
It's like a month, yeah.
September 25th.
Yep.
Yeah.
You only have a month to buy it?
I guess so.
I guess I mean, that's usually how it goes.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, and then there's going to be extra orders, too.
Just like, what's it called?
Just extra stock, just in case, like, you know, some orders
might go missing or something.
You guys have the girl model?
She's so freaking cute.
Yeah.
What?
The one that, in the modeling photos.
Yeah.
Oh, I didn't have the modeling photos.
Wait, can somebody baby feed me?
I don't know.
I don't know if she wore everybody's.
She only wore a men's collection.
She only wore a men's.
Yeah.
That's the man.
Oh.
You guys have the man.
I'm sorry.
Why do you have a picture of the man?
No, I'm sorry.
collection he looks good in my collection that's like
drivers you wear yes you guys look just like him if you wear
this this look just like the professional model if you win
oh yeah you'll turn asian if you aren't already don't worry
stuffy i got you thank you thank you thank you i just went
to the website oh no true oh my god this feels so official
whoa i know right oh my gosh wait this is so cute you guys
okay okay wait i have a question then since it's kind of
university themed what if you guys were like a professor
what class would you teach at schools that's a good question
am i loud in the premises i feel like i feel like it's too
obvious to say like a mint would do like some sort of or
something.
I like the like the singing.
Why?
I was thinking sex ed.
Okay.
At university and that's everybody needs to learn.
You are always learning at your big age.
Welcome to XCOM University.
That way that's XCOM University right there.
cardigan i don't know what i teach i feel i feel like i'd be
an english teacher because sometimes i have arguments with
my chat about proper grammar and and the use of words i
actually we actually had a debate just now because like i
got really confused apparently it's amer an americanism but
but i got completely i got completely thrown off by someone
like the use of the word anymore in regards to like the the
positive anymore so for example the the the post that i saw
and then someone else in my chat said it was the boos that I
saw was IGN anymore is so shit and like we don't use the
word anymore like that I don't know I don't understand I'm
sorry I don't even know what was going on anymore that was
like word salad what did that mean using the word like so
IGN the gaming outlet they were complaining about it and
they said IGN anymore is so shit as in like IGN Now is so
shit.
I don't think they'll use that nowadays.
Yeah, I don't know.
Apparently it's a thing.
No, I got yelled at on my chat because apparently it's a
thing.
I think they told you.
That's just bad grammar.
They just wanted you to like tell them something because
they love it when Lai Mu educates them.
They're like, please Lai Mu.
We're so helpless, please.
I don't know why we're talking about.
Oh, Tymo, can you teach your limo?
Can you do my math homework?
What's wrong with this problem?
I need extra credit.
Yeah, do you teach your limo, please?
Can I have some private tuition?
I'm so confused.
Oh, what class would you teach?
I don't know, honestly.
I feel like, I feel like I'd be like, I guess like, I'll be
like a coach of the varsity teams or something.
Yeah, I just do that and they get paid more than the
teachers too.
So What and wait no if they are running like if they are
coaching one of the better teams in in the University they
do get like cuz like you know college football gets like the
coaches are like our tuition is like insane Oh, yeah, yeah,
like not to decide like the paycheck.
Yeah No, you're doing esports There are some university
classes there are some universities universities that are
now offering esport courses no there is no there's like
collegiate and stuff for esports but there's also did you
hear about how some universities are offering like content
creation courses now what yeah university was just like a
thing for me no but like actual universities are offering
content creation courses or the study of content creation
yeah that's just improv that's
That's crazy.
Do you think it's sort of like computer science where they
teach you how to use like OBS?
Like how do you think you can use Photoshop and editing
programs?
Wait, I took classes like that though, yeah with Photoshop.
Yeah, no, it's all like- I took classes for general computer
use and stuff like that.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, computer science.
That's when they told me how to do the computer classes.
Yeah, but I feel like everybody vibe codes.
I do feel like there was like this weird like pocket of time
where it was like computers got taught in school.
And then it kind of like phased out again, but I hear
they're kind of bringing it out or bringing it back.
Because a lot of people are very tech literate.
My brother didn't do computer classes, but I did.
Yeah, the kids nowadays don't know how to use computers.
I think it's because also because a lot of teachers don't
know as much as the students.
Because a lot of students just learn via online.
So then it feels like a lot of students are just like, well,
I already know this.
So it was like, what's the point?
You know?
I don't know.
I feel like even when I was in computer science, I was like
the forever online kid.
and everyone, even other kids would look at me and be like,
you type really fast, what's wrong?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
This is my whole life.
People being like, why do you type little fast?
But the typing classes were awesome.
I was role playing on Neopets boards while you were a
student.
Yeah, I was.
This shit's gotta go up tonight.
I actually, I didn't realize that I needed to lie about my
age in order to get onto the Neopets forums because like, I
was too young when I signed up and I didn't lie about my
birthday and then they were like, oh, we need your parents
to sign like a letter yeah and then they had to email it to
the neopets team so that you could get onto the forums my my
parents faxed instead of emailing it i was just like hell
yeah slip and then faxed so i can like turn it with my
friends so i can like talk to random strangers online we're
clearly much older than me very
You ever have, did you guys ever have that thing?
I actually, I remember thinking when I was a kid that Gaia
Online was something filthy because when I was on the
Neopets boards, like they were like, oh yeah, so on Gaia
Online, you can do like role play that's not like PG.
And I was like, oh my God, oh my God, that's disgusting.
And then like- I was on the wrong side of the Neopets board
clearly.
But it wasn't even like, it wasn't even explicit.
It was literally just you could say bad words.
Like, I thought because of the way that they were describing
it, the way they did it, I thought it was like something
really like explicit.
So I went on to like an incognito browser and was like
looking at Gaia online.
I was like, wait, it's just anime.
You knew what incognito browser was back then.
That's crazy.
My dad worked in server admin.
He was like, I don't know.
I had to learn things.
That's crazy.
I never did that Gaia online.
I never was at that time got into that.
Because I just didn't look.
It's not like cute virtual pets.
It was like.
I'll be right back.
on the club penguin yeah i was on club penguin i was my
brother was on club penguin he was obsessed i didn't we made
but my class would make fun of there was one kid in my class
that had the subscription we all made fun of him for being
paid a win because we're all free to play we're like what is
the puzzle or whatever this rich kid nerd with her pay to
win subscription my brother was club penguin but i was habo
hotel like oh man habo hotel they just did a collab Yeah,
pools closed.
In the year of 2026.
I won't say on a stream.
You know, they did the, they did the like, uh, family
Neopets is having like a small comeback.
They had like a pop-up shop in New York City.
But like, they saw it.
I mean, they had a Fortnite collab.
Yeah, they did.
Fortnite's doing everything right now.
They're at Halloween Horror Nights for some reason.
Fortnite is basically like, we need the Millennials and
they're just doing everything.
I didn't get the Neopets collab.
I got the Sonic collab though.
I bought Shadow.
Knuckles.
What?
With what?
Fortnite?
Yeah, Fortnite.
Oh, yeah.
Sonic's in Fortnite?
Yes, Sonic is in Fortnite.
They're legitimately doing this, like, focus target right on
millennials right now, and it's just, like, all of the
things from, like, millennial kids is like, we got Sonic.
This season's theme is video games, so, like, Spyro and
Crash Bandicoot are coming in later.
And then, right now, the store has Looney Tunes.
I'm looking at the shop right now.
Looney Tunes.
Master Chief is back in it.
There's a Sonic collection.
Wait, so can you play Sonic?
You can give him a gun?
Yeah, you can give all of his gun.
You can give Homer, I mean...
Is he, like, strangely long, like...
Yeah, no, it's very...
Yeah, dude, I will say...
It looks very off.
I would say that.
I haven't seen this at all.
I feel so, like, under a rock.
That's crazy.
Here, I'll show you the shadow item.
Can we play Fortnite sometimes?
Can we just, like...
We just, like, it's a Fortnite stream now.
I'd have like Sudden pivot everybody reinstalling Fortnite
Is there really lore reasons Why they're so long?
Is that Is that real?
I think it's just to make the models Fair.
They just have to know they have to fit The model of it or
they'll be like No, my chat is saying there's lore reasons
There is?
What's the lore?
Well I know like The Digital Circus is because Like they
stretched POMNI Like that's I like how they made a Peter
Griffin really buff because of it They're like oh yeah we
can't make fat characters because they won't fit the hitbox
and then they made the the giant chicken and people were
like they were like wait a minute that doesn't seem right
wrong they're like way too round in the chest because
they're like stretched so they've got like a their torso is
so wide it just looks like a guy in a shadow costume in a
first right like a guy in the first wait someone said if you
talk to sonic on the island fortnite sonic says that he's an
android so he's not even real he's not even the actual okay
did that with one punch man i remember i miss i'm assuming
it's just like a reason to give lures to the fact that yeah
they have to standardize the character hitbox because
otherwise people would like sweaty try hard and use the one
that was most advantageous yeah you want to use the smallest
use like low graphics to dodge stuff or whatever oh yeah
it's like turn all the bushes off yeah yeah because you turn
foliage all the way down have you seen the marvel rivals
config situation they'll have like where like there's like
no textures gray scale yes it would be like gray scale and
everything's actually created let me take a find it oh my
god it's like it looks like some sort of fucking blender
scene yeah it's like all the textures are removed and we
were like how you played this game at that point like it
gets to a point where it's just like all right you're just
like um this is okay i think are you gonna play there's
another game that did oh yeah yeah i would like to play
peace because it's already 12 30 a.m we need you livo this
is okay we gotta be locked in you got you we need you we
need you we need you i thought you could do this yourself i
might be out of it but we're going we're going yeah wait
wait before it look this is what it looks like basically
the cup oh my god everything's so smooth there's like no
texture why are they green i could i couldn't play like that
it's like it might be super efficient but it's just
optimized there's just a point where i'm like no you know
what i don't need to be that good honestly if you have to
play like that you aren't even that good Oh, shit.
Shots fired.
Infinity gauntlet thrown down.
I said it.
Yeah, no, that looks ugly as fuck, but yeah.
I'm still talking about one big spiral.
You're just now booting it up.
I'm just now booting it up.
Were you been sitting there with it open the whole time?
No, I was.
Yeah.
No, I was in my classroom.
Okay.
I was like on themed guys.
I was on themed with the announcement and every look at
this.
Bam.
I was in a classroom like as if I was in university Yeah,
because you need to go back to school.
Whoa Was that supposed to be to get an even higher
education?
Bam bam.
You know because I'm so smart so I get PhD.
I know I She got two PhDs now, I guess.
Yeah, I must look at it bullshit
I'm I'm technically on at least i finished college and like
school is out right now so school is in school i'm on theme
because the stream is called peak collab and i played i'm on
theme because i'm in the sloppy sisters and that's what it
was all about yeah stuffy's in me stuffy i have i have no
idea which microphone it's using because it just like it
doesn't actually have enough characters it just says that's
it I don't know what the rest of it says I am give me a sec
I'm trying activation okay I just realized my chat overlay
was not even on that entire stream I'm so sorry guys I your
chat what was it on my my I didn't have my chat overlay on
the entire tab oh you were talking to yourself like an
insane person yeah you actually haven't been streaming this
entire time look at the button for push to talk I don't
remember I push to talk why push to mute yeah you want to
hear you want to hear it you don't want to someone that subs
yeah we want to hear it we'll say you want to hear it oh
thank you so much for the 20k billion subs I'm rich 20
kibirion 20 kibirion yeah I got kibirion plus infinity Whoa
YouTube you can gift a billion plus infinity on YouTube yeah
they just added that that's why you gotta come back stuffy
that you could have quadrillion quadrillion quadrillion
infinity plus four I keep wanting to I keep wanting to
stream I keep wanting to stream on on YouTube and then I
like actually look at the interface to set it up and I'm
like I don't know it's so scary it's so It is.
Yeah, I was.
It is.
Oh, someone just gifted me a Cabrillion.
Whoa.
I can't even say that number.
That sounds like a lot.
Wow.
Cabrillion plus one.
Oh, wow.
Did you invite yet?
Wait, who's making it?
How do we?
Oh, my God.
Wait, my dog is not up yet.
Guys, guys, I'm trying.
I'll make it.
Okay.
Why is my Fuggy not working?
What the fuck is the mute button?
I'll just have to experiment.
Wait, I want it here.
Yeah, I want it.
Yeah, let us hear.
We can all celebrate together.
Exactly.
One hella gifted sums.
I don't remember how to play this game.
Okay, invite friends.
Okay, I got the Fuggy to do it.
Oh, my alert's broken.
Now they're just going off over and over again.
That's fun.
Make sure.
All right.
Wait, I only see Doki online.
Oh, do I have to go online?
Oh, I just have to go online.
They're invisible, like, all the time.
Wow.
Can I invade your thing?
You don't want to...
In the airport.
Why can't I join your game?
Did you invite only me?
Let me go online.
I just click toast.
Oh, wait.
I'm online.
Are we doing our usual...
Lower our...
Do we...
Yeah, shut up.
Shut up.
Bye.
Bye, bye, bye, bye, bye.
I don't see you online Actually made me realize have we
somehow never had each other added?
Oh my god, it's not me myself.
I've always that's crazy.
Oh my god.
Oh my god Well, I'm just talking about how this collab took
a year to plan like the merge It is somehow Wait,
you're not friends?
Snuffy.
Yes.
Snuffy and them are not friends damn i just like to watch
the button let's find out okay oh my god what the fuck is
the push to mute yay okay i see you i'll do now i think oh
now i get to see you when you're playing that's so fun yay
you can see all of my be in fuck kingdom oh yeah wait do you
actually
yourself we're doing that lower the volume thing so we see
the thing okay okay can you still hear me can you still hear
me i hear you in game i'm going i'm going you hear me yeah i
hear you i hear you i hear you in the game all right um so
you can tell that i uh beat the game by myself because i
have a yellow pea sash yeah that's right what did you just
say i have my yellow sash no i have my Look at that.
No, it needs to be not.
It needs to be clear.
You can see that my sash is yellow, which means I solo beat
peak.
Oh, she's a flower.
It looks like a little barf-y color.
Which one is it?
Oh yeah, and also I have.
Okay.
You could be a Lolita.
Hello, can you hear me?
Yeah, we can hear looks.
Okay, I'm gonna press a bunch of buttons.
Hello, can you hear me?
Yeah.
Oh, yes.
hear you okay that's not working good fantastic i don't know
why that's not working whatever hear you sound guys can hear
you is my sound okay in game how do you change clothes uh
you could open your passport yeah it's a passport yeah i
don't think i'm only worried about what biomes we're it
because there's some really fucked up items that wait hold
on i'm gonna push to mute can you still hear me after this
oh that's no um i heard you say this don't look at my screen
i don't i don't hear you yuppie i fixed it okay you actually
have to hold the button good times do voice activity we want
to hear everything don't be a don't be a don't be a pussy
i'm doing voice activity i like your stomach growl did you
abort the first attempt to say pussy and then just double in
on it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Don't be a fucking pussy.
Man, unmute yourself now.
I am.
I am unmuted.
I am unmuted now.
If I don't hear Lymo thanking a sub in the next hour, I know
what she is.
Pause, girly.
Thank you so much for the sub, for giving me money.
Thanks.
Who's being you?
whoa whoa i figured out how to climb stuff i guess oh yeah
i'm gonna yeah you guys we got uh wait we got scrimmed guys
wait how do you do we got practice just the left click okay
i'm good i'm good we got practice guys i'm gonna be gonna do
some drills gotta do some trials look yes yes i forget is
holding shift exactly the same amount of stamina expenditure
or is it more this dude jumped okay well oh i don't know
that type of tech
what i've got you okay i think i'm good enough to i'm good
enough to practice me chat i'm good enough to climb a
mountain i'm so excited to see all the different yeah let me
check my settings real quick hi oh hi i'm right clicking
take my hand hi take my hand all right let's go she won't
that way is it like only lobby leaders can is my frames
dropping i can't tell i mean this game runs kind of weird
for me i don't know about you we don't need more i feel like
wait i'm in a pink snow costume what thank you for the rain
i'm gonna just say it really loud over everyone since that's
what we do here yeah they added that what what I feel like I
am lagging a little bit.
How do I drop item?
Oh, how do I turn this off?
It does feel like this is, guys, are your frames dropping?
My frames are dropping for this game a little.
Like, when you say dropping, what do you mean?
Like, 200 frames?
Well, I'm on 100 frames right now for it, but I can feel the
frames dropping a little.
It's always run really badly for me in some of the zones.
Oh, oh, it's so, ah, it's so choppy now.
why am i flying am i flying for you guys looking at my data
doing like a superman no i'm not maxed wait can you guys
hear me yeah i can i can hear you okay i just want to make
sure i'm not too quiet let me check if i have anything open
voice activated i am actually flying no matter where i go
this is epic let me delete some guys i need to close some
tabs real quick give me a sec all right thank you you should
you should make sure you close discord not like close close
but hit the x because it like fucks up your frames wait
really i did not know that it's got yeah like it like as
long as it's like rendering so just hit the x so it
minimizes to taskbar oh really me doing that right now not
all the time but if you're like you know if you're kind of
like flying on the edge a little bit like if i'm playing
league league kind of sucks at utilizing cpus and like i've
noticed it runs worse if i have discord open yeah let's take
some god wait i want to take photos how do you do emotes uh
hold r did you try six seven what's six seven what is that
oh cute big ass lollipop in my face did you not know that
you know it was like directly in front of me like that yeah
oh this is so cute it's so cute there's a backflip I'm
reading snuff the up a little there is you have to go to the
second tab please increase oh there's a second one oh shoot
wait we can crash out oh my god oh my god i'm freaking
crashing out right now what is wrong with me what's wrong
with you stop hopping i know what's going on i thought you
were doing that on purpose no i think is this an e-mode am i
just forever doing this no i don't know why am i only
looking to the side that's weird check my frames real quick
my frame is better now That's weird.
I did not realize this game is poorly optimized.
Like what?
No way.
I feel like this is a game that's optimized.
It might be a me problem.
When I was like a friend set up to do a sponsor and I was
playing rivals, I was like, I've never got 200 frames before
while streaming.
I was like, what is this?
I don't know what's wrong with my PC.
I don't know.
But I'm just cursed with tech.
Honestly, Peak doesn't run that well.
I get slow down in some of the areas.
So it's just not that well optimized.
This is my life.
Now I live in- I live like this.
I mean, I'll say it's a hundred maybe?
I don't think I need that much.
I'm gonna start the game!
Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah!
Make sure you turn cannibalism on!
Wait, how do I do that?
That's a setting?
It'll be in the setting somewhere.
It'll be in setting.
Finally, they let us roast each other.
So when you're hungry enough, you can get your friends.
When you get like a particular amount of hunger, yeah.
Okay, I think my frames are a little better now.
Oh, wow, wow.
Everything is on.
Okay, not everything.
Not everything.
Not everything is on.
Everything is on.
You do not put it on the higher difficulties.
Do not do not do that.
We will not deal with cold.
I do not want to huddle up for warmth.
Everything is on.
Oh, that's so cute, though.
No, it's not.
No, it's not cute.
When you're in game, it is no longer cute.
It is no longer a good thing.
but we get to survive you do not it's on by default i'm
pretty sure the fall it's on settings oh okay okay then i'll
i'll do this we can do another countdown before we take off
mint let's go we're definitely gonna reach the top because i
only have one in me so we have to siding at 100 99 98.
okay guys it's gonna be 1 a.m That's where you unlock your
potential!
I think she gets better, the more sleep-deprived she is.
That's all I'm saying.
The more sleep-deprived she gets, the better she climbs.
At night.
I can't believe our plane crashed again.
Wait, I didn't change.
Wait, are we doing the true ending or no true ending?
Wait, I think I have to reset the room.
Everybody's saying I turned something on that I didn't turn
on.
What did you do?
Are you getting gaslit?
Why did you were like, I'm gonna turn everything on.
This is what happened when you turn everything on.
I turned it on, but then I turned it off.
Why did you do that?
The item weight was set to high, but I didn't change any
item stuff.
Oh no.
It is pretty heavy.
Oh, she turned on a whole cat.
We haven't been anywhere.
She made us hot.
Oh, my God.
She wasn't, she was going to make us hot.
Restart it.
Don't do this to me.
Just do default.
Don't do custom run.
Everybody's saying I click stuff.
I just didn't pay attention.
I'll leave the game.
Just do.
Oh.
All right.
I'll start the room.
Couldn't you just put it back?
Okay.
Cap.
All right.
I guess I'll make the custom room now.
Wait, how do I make it?
Oh.
Wait, actually...
Yeah, never mind.
Oh, wait.
Mint made it.
Alright, never mind.
I go to Mint's world.
Send invite again.
I blew my notes.
Invite again.
Again!
It didn't work!
Alright, now we're in peak.
now we're peeking hello just do default run don't do custom
runs because you don't because we don't get achievements
when we're in okay we're in oh my god I can't believe we
crashed that's fucked up thank goodness we crashed on this
amazing scenic tropical island i know right it's on custom
run but everything's default you guys are just being stupid
no no no no no no if we are cutting you have to do normal
because we don't get achievements we we can get achievements
if we're on custom run man achievements yes we are We
definitely need achievements.
Achievements.
We need to go to the ocean.
Man, if we have achievements, we can lock the little piss
and cheat.
If we can't do something.
I've got something.
100% commitment.
We should try yourself now.
Try yourself now.
End game.
What have you yet to accomplish?
I thought you said you were the number one peeker.
Yeah, but I haven't accomplished some stuff.
Don't you make the room.
Don't you go make the room.
Don't you go make the fucking room.
She doesn't believe in you anymore.
She wants me to make a room.
Oh my God, I need more than you.
Come back, I didn't meet her and I love you.
She's gonna try to kill myself right now.
I got you.
I'm more capable than you.
We're gonna get through this together.
It's like a really shallow ocean.
Yeah, it's a really shallow ocean.
Oh my God.
dice oh man okay well someone make her room she thinks i'm
more reliable than you men
wait she thinks she thinks i'm more reliable than you let's
not go that far let's not go that far i would believe in me
more than you The role play is actually showing.
Crash it out.
No, I'm sorry, man.
I didn't mean it.
I'll make the room, guys.
I'll make the room.
No, no, I'll make the room.
All right.
My turn to make the room.
And now she has to go to my lobby.
All right.
And then, no, she's coming to my lobby.
Oh, no.
Alright, I'm invited Naimu.
And then I invite...
Snuffy.
There you go.
She has to join me.
They have to pick.
Between me or Mint.
They gotta pick.
Wait, I think they picked Mint.
Oh wait, I think they picked her.
No!
I'm here.
What?
Okay, wow, you're so happy to see me.
Yes!
You picked me!
Yeah!
I picked you!
I knew you would never let us play the game if we didn't do
it in your lobby.
And I'm not gonna take it personally, I walked through the
doors and you just say no.
You scream and horror?
I think everybody picked mint So I was screaming in despair
But I know you're a real one I know you're a real one Mint
are kissing right now She said she's gonna go kiss mint a
lot And I was like okay Well I mean yes she has to beg for
her forgiveness Because she She said I'm more reliable than
mint That was crazy I would say 2v2 but then mint has lime
So I'm sorry I'm so reliable I'm not saying you're not
reliable.
I say what both of us combine is only 1% of Lymo's power.
That's not even true.
I thought you soloed it.
You soloed it.
You know Lymo can solo this faster than me.
You know that.
You know it.
No, no.
I think we have better survival instincts than she does.
The bestest peak player is here in my room, so you better
come to my room if you want to win.
She's sending us like magazine cut out like serial killer
hostage things if you don't come to my room in in five
minutes someone's gonna get invited me like five times i
don't are we gonna win this standoff we're holding we're
gonna win this dad i'm sending i'm gonna span limo until she
leaves okay well don't don't neglect me i need to be
convinced why i should stay with you okay because because
you're pretty neat And I'm pretty neat, too.
And we share the same manager.
So, that's true.
We're like, we're like blood brothers.
You mean, like, you know, you could just say blood sisters.
Why are we, why are we blood brothers is like, it's like a
prison thing or something.
Oh, yeah, that's true.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
You make packs.
Yeah, yeah.
And if you don't do it, I'll shank you.
I think blood sisters is like when you sink up, you know.
I'll tell Doki to come to my room.
I'm sorry.
I mean, stop it.
Seven cents into me instead of you.
Is she sending you this on Steam?
Yeah.
I still have, I exit Discord out because of what Limeu said,
so I'm blind to any communications.
Well, she has to come here.
She thinks she has sent me an invite like 30 times.
I'm just sending Limeu an invite.
Limeu has to pick.
It's like a divorce.
Every time I tap into Steam, there's more invites.
Can I invite her too?
Yeah, invite Lymo.
You invite, we both will two-time.
We'll double-team her.
So she'll get double- Oh my god!
Okay, alright.
But only on Lymo.
Because then, Min will have to come crawling back if we
grab...
If we grab Lymo, Min will come crawling back.
I thought Lyman was gonna come.
What did Mint has her hostage or something.
I think so.
I think Mint is holding her hostage.
There's no way she's there.
Like, with her consent.
There's no way.
I don't believe it.
We made a deal.
I was like, okay, I'm gonna join Doki.
And she's like, okay, I'm gonna go tell Mint I love her.
And then I'll join.
But she never came.
She must be held hostage.
She must be held hostage right now.
She has her tied up.
They're plotting against you.
It's a trade war.
It's a civil war.
It's a sloppy sister's civil war.
right now.
This is just like the Avengers.
Yeah, I know.
Who's Captain American?
Who's Iron Man?
Who's it?
I think you're Iron Man.
I'm Iron Man.
Yeah.
Yeah, you're Iron Man.
I'm Iron Man.
Captain America.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Dang it.
We have the better.
Wait, who are you my Peter Parker?
Yes.
I think so.
I show up and I'm just like, what's up, everybody?
Hey, guys.
What's up?
I'm Peter Parker.
I'm going to send her stickers of like my like porn games or
something on the screen.
Limu has to come.
Well, I'm going to message her.
I'll be like, I don't know what to say.
You have to give a slogan.
I'll be like, Limu, I'm more stubborn than men.
You should come home.
Limu.
I'm more stubborn.
I sent her a picture of like a sexy furry.
gonna call her and she said that in her peak lobby she has
those in there.
the end of peak come here.
Mint says she has sexy furries in her peak lobby.
That's a good argument.
I think I want to...
Should we go get the furries?
How do we get the furries?
Mint has them in her lobby.
She does not have the furries.
There's no way.
That's what she said.
That she's just lying.
It's just propaganda to tempt you.
Propaganda!
Peak lobby propaganda.
Oh yeah, if she has...
Does she have...
Gnomes, though?
I'm not gonna...
Oh yeah, yeah.
I'm not a gnome.
Yeah, maybe I can entice her with that.
I'm a gnome.
We have gnomes and magical fairies.
Oh, I'm a gnomes.
And you've been gnomes!
Come live whimsically in our lobby.
Okay, I sent her my own little link.
Yeah, tell her, tell her we have...
Oh, yeah, yeah, can she do this?
Ha!
Did I do it?
She says she's riding horses in her lobby, though.
That's a lie.
Oh, yeah?
Does she have a pretty girl like me right now?
Oh, my God.
That's right.
Does she have Lolitas?
Tell her, tell her, tell her we have Lolitas.
We have Lolitas in my room.
We're putting on a fashion show.
I'm so nervous, guys.
Oh my gosh, oh my gosh!
You're so cocky.
I'm- I'm like, Kauai-i, snuffy, chad.
Oh, yes, yes!
Oh, yeah!
Oh, my gosh, we!
That's what, that's what she's missing out!
That's what she's missing out right now.
We're gonna start her game now.
We're, they're gonna start with our game.
We're gonna start our game then, too!
Oh my god, we're gonna miss them so much.
We're missing our green colors.
Yeah, they're gonna miss us too.
They're gonna miss us as well.
They're gonna miss us.
They started!
Come on, Stuffy.
Come on.
Get over here, Stuffy.
Get up.
But it's like you said with Limer, they're gonna win.
I thought you believed!
What happened?
You make rash decisions.
What do you mean?
But have you won with the with a player?
I got it.
This will make us go faster.
Right here.
This will
Don't worry.
I made sure I made sure we'll get there faster than them.
I don't worry.
I have I made sure you will be faster than them, no matter
what.
No.
Get it.
Come on.
Come on, Stuffy.
We're going peaking, right now.
Okay, okay, okay.
We're peaking, we're peaking.
Go.
Go grab these, grab these.
All right.
Grab this, grab this, grab this.
Grab this, okay.
Grab this.
We will beat them.
We need to backpack.
The Sloppy Sister Civil War.
No.
I got all this super useful stuff.
Come on, stuffy.
Get over it.
Pick up.
Pick this up.
I'm coming.
I'm going up and grabbing coconuts.
This is a sloppy sister civil war.
No!
I am Iron Man.
Okay, I'm Spider-Man.
It just means that I'm going to be better at climbing.
Alright.
Let's go.
I haven't played this game in a while.
Wait, don't use up the trumpet.
The trumpet has a new buff where you...
Wait, is that the same trumpet?
Never mind.
It's not the same.
You can do whatever the hook you want.
There's a trumpet where if you play it, it'll give you
unlimited stamina.
That's right.
We got this.
That's true.
If we win, we didn't have Lyme.
If they win, they had Lyme.
That's right.
The perfect solution.
It's less of a brag because they had Lyme moves.
But if you win, it's not a brag because they expect us to
fail?
No, if we win, if we win, that means we're better.
That means we never needed Lai-Mu.
We've unlocked her.
We've unlocked her third eye.
I need her smell.
Wait, there's like a blue beam up there.
What's that?
Oh, that's the thing.
I don't think that's a secret ending.
A secret?
Does that mean we win?
Yeah, there's a true ending.
it when i was solo because i had no more space in my
inventory because you have to grab like four uh oh you have
to grab four and then uh and then you have to take it all
the way to the end and there was like no point in doing that
we got this stuffy we got this i also read how to climb okay
wait not here not here i don't know the the route though
come over here stuffy in and out stuffy quick adventure
teamwork teamwork okay go here go here here wait wait wait
on me okay okay okay stuffy just imagine imagine how cool
it'll be if we beat team minute limo just imagine we're
gonna be heroes tv show is my little pony and i think
Friendship is magic.
We are the magic, Snuffy.
But we didn't really work for Smuffy.
They left us!
They left us, Snuffy!
Just remember, they left us!
That's true.
We didn't leave them!
Come on, Snuffy!
We can do this!
We will beat Peek!
Wait, we're on the same map too, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, it's the same.
Cool.
There's no difference.
Can we climb up here?
That's right.
No, I am more spiteful.
I can't believe we announced a group merch.
And then we have a group merch collaboration.
We're entering the long questions.
Can the Swappy survive without Lymo?
It's just, it's like a statistic.
And we remove Lymo.
Can they survive on an abandoned island?
in one singular video game it immediately breaks up the
group i didn't break up the group i wasn't the catalyst chat
should we have like a poll like who do you think is gonna
win how do i help you uh it's right click okay we have to go
go this way okay okay oh you can point how do you oh there's
this middle mouse button They're gonna vote for like you
guys are my chat.
You're gonna vote for Lymo.
Okay, to be fair I would also vote for if I wasn't involved
in this I would also vote for Lymo, but only because you're
like competitive and you won't even I won't because I kept
you every time Every time Lymo has saved our lives every
time This was meant I exact mint did this just remember this
is the prophecy this is gonna be on your test or like on the
card plays well with others fail dude that looks like a dead
end is it i think it's fine no no no that looks cursed that
looks no no it's fine just believe stuffy just believe you
gotta believe believe in the power of friendship
it's gotta believe
I didn't make it.
Oh, oh, I didn't make it.
There's just nothing up there.
I didn't make it.
Okay, maybe you're right.
Maybe you're right.
Maybe we should go this way.
Yeah, yeah.
Wait, wait, wait.
I think the other way.
There's...
Wait, wait, wait.
This is doable.
Okay, I'm coming.
I'm coming.
This is doable.
Okay.
Okay, and then...
Maybe this one?
Yeah, yeah.
Careful, the poison jellyfish.
Okay, maybe you're right.
Maybe you're right.
Let's go back down.
Oh, my God!
That's okay.
This only sets us back a little bit.
There's nothing on the little bit.
We're just a little behind.
Now we're gonna, if we fail this, Limeu will probably tattoo
it onto her arms in our grave.
Yeah, but we know what she is.
We know what she is.
Us accomplishing this is like Like, no one believed in us,
you know?
Nobody believed us, Stephanie.
So, like, the odds are, like, a billion to what?
Like, like, people, the cash out for this will be millions
of dollars because nobody would have betted on us, you know?
What is there to say?
Like, let it be known, you guys.
We can function on our own.
Yeah, we don't need her.
Did we go the wrong pathway?
Did we?
Maybe we need...
I think this way...
Yeah, yeah.
Like, hmm, maybe like up above here.
Oh, wait.
There's like, you can stay here.
Oh, there's a suitcase over there, though.
Ooh, ooh.
Look at this.
Come up here.
Oh, don't worry.
I'm here, stuffy.
You gotta go left.
Here, do you see my arms?
No, I don't see you.
Where are you?
Just keep going left!
Where did you go?
Oh, no.
I don't know.
Are you up?
I'm up.
You're up?
Wait.
Alright, Stuffy, I think we need to slip let up.
Stuffy, Stuffy, I'm going up.
I'm going up, Stuffy.
You're going up?
I'm going up.
Just keep going up, Stuffy.
Somebody just keep going up.
Just keep going up.
Just keep believing.
This will not have bad consequences.
No, nothing bad's going to happen.
Just keep going up.
This is going to be okay.
I think she'll be fine.
If anything, I'll rez her.
Stuffy, just keep going up.
Just keep going out, stuffy.
If you keep going up, we'll be fine!
Keep going up!
Oh, I don't need that.
Whatever.
It's okay, I don't need that.
As long as she keeps going up, we'll make it.
Snuffy, did you go?
Went up?
Did you keep going up?
Just keep going up, Stuffy!
Keep going up!
It's the only way!
Stuffy, we'll be fine!
Use your items!
Wait, wait, Juki, are you somewhere near me now?
I don't know, are you?
You sound close, too!
Did you do my strat?
Do you do my going up strat?
I'm going up too
Oh my god, wait a minute.
I'm already there
Snuffy if you have to die you can die just use your items
Use the grapple hook to get up
Snuffy I'm already up Snuffy I'm already here I'm already
here Snuffy
Use the items!
I'll wait for you at the end.
Stuffy, you can die if you have to.
I'll res you.
Just die.
Use your items, Stuffy.
I'm right here.
I hear you.
I hear you, Stuffy.
I'll be right here.
When I see it, I'm at the top.
You're at the top?
When you're here, I hear you!
Oh my god, some of you Our strap worked Our strap worked
We did it
No, no, no, no, no I'm here, I'm here Go, let's go, let's
go, let's go I'm here, I'm here, yeah, yeah, our strategy
Yes, okay Making a good time, I don't know Yeah, yeah, we're
making a good time, see?
Teamwork
Teamwork, guys That's how you do it Alright Is the hot dog
special?
You have to cook it?
No, it's the same.
Yeah, cook it And then, you don't have to eat it But I'll
eat these berries Alright, we can get special item
Okay, oh the anti-rope That's actually pretty good for us
Alright, this one!
We got this!
Oh, eat the fruit if you need to if you're hungry Are you
hungry?
Oh, uh No, okay, I'm gonna eat this.
All right.
We got this.
Power of friendship, stuffy.
In the backpack.
I'll put this in your backpack.
Okay.
All right.
I don't think we...
Do you think they already won?
Do you think they already won it all?
I don't know.
Okay, okay, which way...
Which path are you thinking?
Are you getting the big picture here?
Are you taking it all in?
You know what?
stuffy why don't you lead us for this area what stuffy i
believe in you you literally excelled i'm i don't know okay
okay okay you're right you're right you're right i think i
think we should do the the right side though okay nicer the
thing is is because i played peak alone solo when i beat it
so i i i'm more of a solo player right now mindset so i need
great i'm like a lost dog
roll reel me back I need you to hold me back you know or
I'll disappear I'm more like a small dog maybe so I'm just
trailing behind on the leash okay okay I think I'm like more
to the right though looks more to the right I trust you
wait where did stuffy where did you go okay okay okay over
here what are you holding right now Why are you holding the
lantern?
I found it.
What's it good for?
Oh, it's for the warmth.
Wait, it's the warmth, but we don't really need it because
it's not cool.
We'll need it if there's a snow biome.
I don't think there is a snow biome.
We should start climbing here.
Yeah, this is where I think it'll be good.
In my...
I don't know if the canyon...
A balloon!
A balloon, Sophie!
Oh, balloon!
You should have it.
Take it, take it.
It helps you climb faster.
What?
you here right now uh you don't have to we should do it when
you're like climbing more so when we're starting to climb
higher wait where'd you go right here i'm here right as
always i think doki's actually my imaginary friend right
here i'm right behind you careful of the vines though be
careful they might have like the little trap stuff too oh
yeah when it rains it when it rains it's harder to climb
remember that okay right do you think we can climb up here i
think uh we get to that vibe i don't think so i don't think
this is a good area of the cloud honestly
maybe that maybe back here
oh this is weird
Looks quite challenging.
Maybe I'll check up.
I think maybe here.
This feels like better.
Okay, okay, yeah.
They all doubted us.
Lime will doubted us.
We'll prove all of them wrong.
Prove them all wrong.
I don't know if they ever did.
I don't know if they doubted us.
If they believed in us, they would be in my room.
they could say the same about us though did we believe in
them of course we believe in them they have lime oh that's
true what are we saying where are you can we even live
without life we're show them we can live without it wait
wait stuffy can you i'm gonna throw this to you can you
catch it all right all right because i need to put this in
my backpack
All right.
Okay, I put it in your backpack.
Climb.
Click climbing.
Oh, careful, careful, careful.
Ah, careful, careful.
The trap, trap, trap.
And there's one up top.
There's one up top.
Okay, okay, okay.
I got it.
I'm going at an angle.
Look at that.
Teamwork!
All right.
Thank you.
Okay, well, that's poison.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, poison.
Yeah, poison these.
This is the route.
Oh, Min invited me to play Peek.
What did they lose?
Did they lose?
They come crawling back.
Oh, my God.
They're probably already eating each other's bones right
now.
They're crawling back.
Oh, they must miss us so much, though.
Oh, yeah.
They must have They wish we were there, too I wish they were
here It's gonna be a beautiful lesson about like it's all
about the friends and and what is an accomplishment if If
your friends aren't even there with you.
Oh, there's a fellow.
We can't really need a fanny pack.
You don't have space We could wait is that space?
No, you have a checkpoint flag.
Oh, okay.
Checkpoint is good.
Yeah.
Okay, I'm gonna are you holding?
hungry a little bit all right eat the coconut okay and i'll
put that here just in case we break our legs okay and i
think we go here and then oh i don't think apparently they
just got their first peak we're already past that oh my chat
says they want us to join so they can res us to be to play
with them but that sounds like a weird mentality for wait
wait wait wait wait i got an idea How about, how about we
res, you guys?
It begins again.
Yeah, what if we res you guys?
Even dust.
Yeah, we can offer them like, oh, you're at the first
checkpoint?
Well, we're already at the second checkpoint.
Oh, oh, mid-touch the statue?
Huh.
We're gonna, we're gonna be on the second checkpoint too.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, that's right.
You know, I'll be the bigger person, and I'll be like,
Wait, say we're better.
And I'll restart.
Guys, my teammate is too busy fucking typing in chat.
BM, BM, your AFK in chat typing.
I almost fell to my death while you were typing that.
Man, summon the Scoutmaster!
Has she summoned the Scout?
Wait, what does that mean?
to get scout master the scout master kills you what she
summons the scout master
wait wait wait mid message she said
she sent me a message saying we're better
All right, I said say stuffy and doki are better Oh My gosh,
it's like saying uncle it's sloppy sloppy uncle I was like
restart the game wait Make it mid say it now
We did it stuffy we won the civil war oh my god you should
really we are strong strong the masses united we can we we
together strong we are amazing don't worry I got the proof I
got the proof I'm gonna send it on discord that is my alarm
every day I got the proof right here i got it yeah you see
it see it stuffy yeah i mean i'll just have this on my
screen forever now we are better okay wait let me tell limo
your turn limo oh my god
I restart the lobby.
I want to fucking go to bed.
Livo is in purgatory now.
So what do we do?
Are they going to join us or do we have to restart?
We have to restart the lobby.
I got to restart.
Let me restart.
Oh, shit.
And then we can talk about how good we are the whole time.
I know.
Oh, my God.
All right.
Are you ready?
I'll see you in lobby again i i what if they what if they
don't join dude what if they they have to they have to no no
no what if this is sabotage no no there's no way there's no
way there's no way we already made it further than them we
made it further we didn't but they're gonna they're gonna
they're gonna keep playing well we're gonna restart yeah and
then and then and then we're gonna beat them again we're
gonna beat them get ready i'll see you there i'll see you
there okay okay
Well, we know the route now.
I'm making lobby now.
Alright, post game.
Alright, here we go.
I'm back at it again.
Alright.
And then...
I won.
I did it.
I'm more speedy.
spiteful.
Will they really join?
Oh, oh, Lymo said re-invite.
Lymo said re-invite.
I won.
Is it really happening?
It's happening.
They're really gonna join?
I can't believe they won.
It's happening.
We won.
Snoopy?
Hello.
Fellow scouts.
Hello, Captain America.
We missed you guys so much.
excuse nothing we made it we made it to the campfire and
then mint got a bugle and then we called the scout master
and she tanked the hit it was great i did you take them you
take your scout master he picked her up and then dropped her
i don't know oh my god it was awesome oh yeah her power was
too immense for him where'd you guys make it to yeah we
almost made it to the i think they were in the jungle we
were in the jungle yeah we made it to the top yeah yeah well
we know the top of the first round for it so for the first
part so that should be fast are we doing are we doing we
went to the weird purple mist first and i don't know what it
really did but we went there oh it's the blue the blue thing
yeah yeah okay so do you always want to do true ending or a
regular ending so for true mini has two hours and i have two
hours can we do two and two i don't know we can do true
ending i don't know but we true ending basically each each
region has like a thing item we have to pick up and then we
have to have all four items at the end.
That's the true end.
I mean, we can pick the item up and if we happen to manage
it, we happen to manage it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So each item I have to, I don't remember what each item
does.
That's the thing.
But if you use the item, it limits your stamina.
Each use.
So, like, that's the bad part.
Did you notice that, Slimeo, when you used it?
No, I just got, like, a medallion and it didn't do anything.
I used it.
Okay.
Alright.
Start.
it guys guys look at that look at that guys we came back
together we came back together and reunited came back
together and we freaking crashed in your lobby doki because
oh and you crashed on your lobby as well no we didn't crash
we didn't crash getting everything the flus is alive i put
that on my butt oh wait that's min oh my god that was min
because she's yeah min's got the backpack now where am i
yeah give it to me give it to me doki bird no Oh my god.
All right.
Let's go.
What route did you guys do?
We just went up to the blue thing.
Yeah, we just like, we just vibed.
We just go to the blue.
We hung out on the beach for a chunk of time and then
weandered.
Snuffy and not we sped her on.
We had passion in our climb.
The two sides of the corner I heard you left a snuffy
behind, though.
No, no, no.
We were like...
No, no, no, no.
It was a strategy.
This was a strategy.
We both made it to the top.
Snuffy, I heard that.
I'm grabbing coconuts for us.
We need coconuts.
Okay, what's the ancient luggage?
What?
Oh, you get damage if you open it.
Oh.
Well, well.
Oh, it's a bugle.
Oh, no.
You definitely won't die if you do.
No, the bugle gives you unlimited stamina.
If you use it.
Really?
Yeah.
That's the thing.
So like when we're climbing, someone has to play the bugle
and we can have unlimited of stamina when we're climbing so
it's like it's not that bugle oh it's not that one you got
the evil bugle the scout master's bugle you got oh yeah do
not know play the bugle play the bugle play the bugle play
the bugle play the bugle play the bugle we should play the
bugle at the end and make it more exciting that the scout
master chases why that means we have to carry it the whole
time come on don't be a baby oh no yeah yeah yeah Yeah,
yeah, yeah, that's my tootie.
That's my tootie.
You'll get an achievement, Snuffy.
Don't you want an achievement?
Oh, yeah.
That's what Doki said.
We have to do it all for the achievement.
No, it's all for the achievement.
That's why we remade the fucking lobby!
No, we made, we remade the lobby because I won.
What?
I won.
I won the civil war.
The second time.
I won.
Doki won the war that only she was participating in.
We are all very happy for her.
No, no, Stuffy was there.
He definitely only won a battle.
What was the route for the...
What was the route that you did, Lai-Mu?
We didn't go for the true ending.
Honestly, this looks about right.
We kind of meandered because Seaman immediately fell off the
cliff.
A little bit.
A little bit of falling off the cliff.
Did we go this way?
Yeah, we went to the right.
We went to the right.
I think it was this way.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, we just have to not die so we can get, like, the
secret items.
I don't know if Snuffy wandered off while playing the bugle,
but she might be dead.
Oh.
No, she's not.
She's not.
She's doing the other route.
I can hear her in the distance.
You don't believe in Stuffy.
I believe in her because she was my teammate.
I believe in you, Stuffy.
I mean, my child is yelling on you.
I've earned the respect of my peers.
Okay, we have...
Wait.
Wait, we need mint so we can put stuff in the back.
Wait, who has space?
Because I don't have space.
I have space.
There is this.
I grabbed it.
All right, what's the route you used?
that i moved this one uh this way oh wait did you it's not
it's not a massively efficient route yeah you can put stuff
in my oh no in my butt in her fat pack i think we're good
okay we're good we don't need i think we're good we can just
walk up here yeah yeah this is walkable oh my bad wait i
gotta have a free hand this is walkable you too busy
slurking it yeah stuffy has the best Oh my gosh, I've never
gotten so many compliments I'm gonna say my wife I didn't
leave her to die I knew she was a strong independent raccoon
So you didn't leave her though No, I said I didn't leave her
behind I literally, I gave her instructions I was like, just
keep going up And she took my instructions Yeah, I have like
motivational speaker dokey Yeah, I was like, just keep going
up Just do it Just do it, keep going up We lost mint We left
mint behind She has everything She's there She said, come
on, man.
Why can't you just leave me behind, huh?
I'm here.
Why were you waiting for you?
Mushrooms over here.
Don't eat it.
I don't know if those are your save, man.
Do not eat the mushrooms.
Okay.
You might not be able to make it to the bridge if you eat
the mushroom.
Stop putting things in your mouth.
I'm eating all of them because I don't want to share with
you guys.
Why the hell am I suddenly your enemy?
Wait, yeah, why did...
Oh, wow, wow.
I'm waiting for you!
Stop here for you and you call her out!
Wait.
There's like a spot to stop here, right there.
There you go.
Yeah.
And then across here and then there.
I need like...
Yeah, I remember.
Why did you do this one?
This is FB.
I think it's because you're carrying less stuff, right?
What?
I have a Fanny pack.
Oh, wait, come with more stuff.
I got it.
Thank you.
Yay!
Thank you, buddy.
I remember one point I readjusted the route and I can't
remember where I did it so it's gonna be fun which way
what's in that one chain launcher oh we're gonna meet that
yeah oh look we made it yeah I just don't remember what each
of the item does though so that's gonna be the problem Oh, I
think that replicates items, I think.
Not too sure.
Sounds like it.
You could replicate my chain launcher.
The generosity sounds like that.
And my axe.
There you go.
Replicate my chain launcher, maybe.
Yeah, if someone wants to pick it up.
How do you do it?
Just pick it up.
You look sick.
Am I sick?
Yeah, are you okay?
I don't...
What do I look like?
You're kind of pale.
Yeah, you look like you ate maybe a mushroom or something.
You should have.
How do I duplicate it?
I don't...
actually no use it over the item i guess well someone does
it work all right wait no min you should do it oh why me you
should do it i believe in you because you're so generous
because you're such a generous friend you you literally said
it i feel like there's a savage time going on yeah well i'm
not too sure about that it was just a theory that guy
retired okay i can't i don't believe in with game theories i
don't need i don't need a crutch all right five i'm gonna
there you go i depleted my stamina someone else pick it up
take this thing with us yes you have to for the true ending
okay holding okay okay i have to drop my backpack oh wait my
backpack's full i guess i gotta eat my mushrooms don't drop
your backpack backpack very important okay why are we giving
in all the important items though like doing a good job
holding on to them okay all right is anyone hungry because i
have coconuts i'm a little bit hungry i'm gonna take the
other two coconut half i've been snacking i've been thank
you there's one more coconut up here i can grab that looks
like a couple actually i can only fit one in my inventory
all right i got another coconut to hold on to oh someone
said you'll be able to It's your extra stamina?
Yeah, that's what it does.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, that's why I...
Oh, I just used it.
Oh, wait, I thought you made it.
Whoops.
Yeah, I'll get you back.
What happened to being a team player, huh?
Well, I saw you climb at the edge.
I thought you made it.
Clearly, I didn't.
Yeah, no, no, no.
Wait, Stuffy, where did you go?
Oh, yeah, we went around the backside of this spot.
We went up here this way.
Yeah, it's good.
Oh, where did she go?
Snuffy?
I'm here.
Oh.
Oh, there you go.
I was, we went this way for our route.
Yeah, this is the same way.
Or did we go this way?
No, I don't know.
No, we went that way.
This is, this is correct.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
The route was super easy around this way.
See, the teamwork makes the dream work.
Is red safe?
Oh, there's food.
Yes, it's, it's safe.
Oh, you're a food tester?
Thank you.
Are you are you food safety certified?
Yeah, he's yeah.
She's the FDA for everything on this map.
I promise you She's the FDA FOB-certified FDA board member
We are not getting any diarrhea lettuce anytime soon guys.
Don't worry I actually don't remember if this is the way we
went.
I don't think it is but it looks fine.
This was my I think we went up here.
Yeah, this is right.
We went around.
Yeah.
This way it was my route.
I don't think this is like you're walking the same path oh
my god we're united again we settled our differences to work
together united again and it feels magic everybody
where do we go now thank you this is a different this is a
little bit of a different route from mine this this is not
the way we went we didn't go this way oh which way did you
we went left from where we just moved there I don't know
about this route yeah I didn't go this way we went along
this way you see here okay stealthy went that way for her
route and then wait I think we could do something here you
pick your hand yeah yeah there's a route here there is yeah
yeah I see the route I see the route they climb up here this
is sand Yeah, there you go.
I'm falling over here Oh, splitting up yet again No, this
route This is the way we went last time.
I mean we made it we're already at the top guys Bye guys.
I love you Civil War two, I guess postcard.
I guess we're on the second Guys stop it stop it
I just want to see what it does.
I've never done it before.
Oh, look at that.
We made it.
Is this milk?
Fortified milk.
They don't trust our...
They don't trust...
Oh, where are they?
Are you guys going to go my route now?
Oh, no.
No.
I almost got it.
No, we're waiting for you guys.
We're waiting Still climbing I see Still climbing forever
now you can go Does the poison go away?
I think it goes away though, right?
It goes away.
Yeah, eventually.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Don't eat the yellow apples That was bad.
Did they fall?
You know why you guys are climbing or feed my dog?
I'll be right back.
Bye
Come this way, come this way, come this way, come this way.
Yeah, you should be making your own, making your own purple
things.
Man, that looks hard, you guys.
Can I, I'm just gonna heckle you from at the top.
Ah!
Why did it sound like, don't you just go up the mountain?
No!
Oh my god, were you playing?
Oh, hey.
Oh my god, did she just play the show?
I was gonna say
Oh, yeah, yeah stuffy kept playing the bugle
Let's go master the skill master's here.
Yeah, yeah, oh look at him go.
Wow.
Wait, what do we do?
Oh my gosh Oh my gosh He got the coconut Oh shit Oh shit
I'll grab it And I'm gonna eat it Is that feel okay?
She's okay.
Yeah, look, she's great.
She's doing great.
She's having fun while you guys were getting up here.
I got Pandora's lunchbox.
I don't remember what this does.
Oh, oh.
Oh, wait, the yellow ones are not safe.
Uh oh.
Yeah, the yellow ones are not safe.
Wait, but I ate them before and I was fine.
Yellow ones should be safe, I thought.
Well, she got poison, so I don't know.
Remember to cook your coconut.
green that's not safe wait how do i open the coconut um you
just throw it throw it against the wall throw it at my head
oh okay let's try it didn't work maybe not hard enough oh
there we go it's a cooked coconut you guys it's delicious oh
yeah yeah i need to cook this one too hot dog uh i'm okay
put this one half yeah you can have that half i'm gonna put
this other coconut what does the pandora lunchbox do my
chest doesn't randomize your shot your staff I don't know
what that means.
I'm not gonna test that up.
Does anyone want the backpack?
It scares me.
I have a backpack already.
Wait, what is this?
Oh, I have a chain.
I have a rocket launcher.
Because you got such a good fanning.
Whoa.
Are you guys ready?
Thank you, ma'am.
Yeah, let's go.
Stephanie and I took a route this way.
So, I will follow.
Oh, I see the there is a suitcase here.
Do we have inventory space yeah I have really but maybe we
can switch things out I have I can hold one item one item
yeah I go one right there is a suitcase over there oh I see
it how the heck would we even get over there yeah yeah the
thing is I don't know where I don't know where the the true
ending stuff is though on this area it's up there at the
very top on the right it's on the right then we'll have to
climb on right then oh it raining down yeah those are going
down to the left i think
i'm just heading down i'm down now where are you guys i'm
down you guys down all right guys we got oh man why didn't
you how what's your leg like what's your leg like uh i i
grabbed the wall and i didn't okay okay that's good Island
oh Yeah, I have half stamina You're gonna climb up there
why?
There's a suitcase up there Unless we don't want it We don't
have to get it There's like There's a suitcase right here We
have a lot of suitcases everywhere They're always bickering
Aren't they I know We're a better team We made it We made it
ahead Okay, that's a good balloon I just found balloons Is
red good I had a balloon before Yeah, red is good Oh, we
don't know if it's good here Scorchberry.
It looks spicy.
Oh, Scorchberry.
I'll try it.
Oh, isn't Scorchberry to warm you up?
I don't remember.
Oh, don't eat that, by the way, guys.
Don't eat that!
What about this?
Eat this.
The red Chrisberry should be fine.
Alright.
Dude, I have so much extra stamina right now.
I'm, like, driving.
Yeah, but we shouldn't use it.
We need to save it.
Where's the Scoutmaster thing?
You already used it.
No, I meant it.
the new one.
The new one.
No, we can't do it twice, but what's the new Scoutmaster?
Oh.
We climbed we did here, and then we climbed this.
No, we did, because that's the new suitcase.
We did.
I don't know where we were.
We did it here, and then we climbed this, and then we
climbed this.
I remember now.
Yeah, I was about to say, doesn't that look like a better
route?
This?
Left or right?
Left, right, or right, right?
Let's go left, since you went right before all right we
didn't make first i don't know we made it really far though
on the left side before we got caught out the left or the
right side because we went right uh it's in the middle
middle should be fine i don't know the thing is i don't know
where the true ending is that's where i'm most worried about
hey oh i made it we made it oh wait i need this oh the
purple ones are Help!
Help!
Oh, yes she did make it!
Lival!
Grab my hand!
I'm falling too.
I'm falling.
I'm here.
You guys grab my head.
I didn't want to use my bonus stamina.
All right.
Thank you.
Oh no.
Help.
Thank you.
I got you.
All right.
Now we can climb up here.
Okay.
What happened now that they're together?
Power of friendship.
reunited and we settled our differences and now we're
stronger than ever oh i remember this so we went here be
careful of these these are poison oh right yeah this is i
feel like with all of us this suddenly becomes worse here i
know what you did is he gone i know what you did
I'm fine.
I was looking at the fuse on Doka board's back about two
seconds before Mint saw the same thing.
Hey I'm glad that we were all on the same page.
I didn't touch it.
Don't touch that thing.
Doki, you just let out a fart so loud that you just
exploded.
What can I say?
Wait, I can't hear you.
I can't hear you.
Are you muted?
I think you're muted.
Do you love us?
I hope I hope you never make it to the top mint.
I hope you I like I like how it was in the middle of a
monologue about how the power of friendship was able to
enable us to find your body in a ditch one day.
I hope you live forever and prosper.
Hey, I'm not looking back anymore.
Hey, I didn't touch the fuse.
I'm not looking back.
She was the fire that ignited the flame, you know?
Yeah.
Beautiful poetry right there.
Thank you.
I was literally just like thinking of the last time that we
had played that fireworks scene.
I didn't go to you in a different way.
Let me grab this.
Where did you guys go?
Who has inventory space?
I didn't know.
Well.
Who has inventory saved?
Oh, no, I'm trying to get us items, okay?
I'm trying to be helpful.
My fanny pack.
Excuse me?
I don't know the route for this one, though.
This is the furthest we made it.
It is this way.
Thank God I had the med kit because I know someone was not
going to use it.
actually I'm pretty hurt what did that actually oh mint is
damage for what it's worth what what did that actually do
because I was too far down the cliff I just saw the
fireworks it would launch me all the it would launch me high
ground but because we were against the mountain it obviously
made me hit my head and then drop back down and I hit the
poison and then I also broke my leg and then thank I forgot
I had a med kit that healed all of it before I fucking
passed out.
I like how you just reappeared very quickly too.
Then I had a bad dream and then I got a splinter.
Oh, I think I went the wrong way.
Oh, I went the wrong way.
Did you hit your head again?
I hit my head and then I got a splinter.
I I found the route I need I have the next pathway This way
here He has come back I'm waiting and got you guys in my
hands Yeah, stuff he has there's like no respawn here
though.
Hold on.
It's like a plan Yeah, just do you I don't have any heal
items on me unfortunately because Because I wish I had that
med kit earlier.
I...
Yeah, I wish you had that med kit too.
Because I'm, like, in a bad situation.
I'm very stingy about my stamina.
Oh, yes.
Alright, here we go.
Thanks.
And then we got Climb from up here.
You might have to stay there to keep that move back up.
We're okay.
Thank you.
Alright.
We're really...
Waiting for Snuffy.
What is it?
Checking, I'm scouting.
She's scouting, guys.
Okay.
Yeah, this is safe.
This is safe.
I'm in the safe area.
Wait, where did you go, Nogi?
Up here, up here, here, here, here.
I saw her at the back of the door.
And I climbed this up and I'll add my head up.
Oh.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Her solo beat peak.
Huh?
I don't know if I can make this.
Oh, thank you.
We got you.
All right.
If we find a healing thing, needs it because apparently
she's kind of dying oh no someone said to you something in
my fanny pack hold on what is in your fat i'll look at it oh
you got maybe this way no she doesn't have it over this way
this looks good well i am i think she's actually damaged
yeah but like if she eats it she has extra stamina though
she gets extra stamina she eats it i've got the stamina
careful don't don't go right don't go left side man there's
a poison bush yeah i see it i see it we're almost there oh
there it is we need to get that we need to get that for the
trending yeah yeah yeah which but oh i see it i forgot to
climb that though it looks a bit funky i think we need to
probably go around the side and then loop in maybe yeah oh
limo apparently the lunchbox you have will heal me well it's
a gamble look in my backpack It's a gamble.
Because it's a Pandora's box.
Yeah, so you might not.
If you want to let it ride, you can.
Let's do it.
What else could possibly happen if you gamble?
It basically remixes all our stats.
It does a remix.
Where did you guys end up?
We're up here.
What does that mean?
Are you opening it?
Can I put this?
I opened it.
It actually works.
Oh, that is.
Yes!
Wait, can I...
Is this a one-time use?
I don't know.
Yeah.
Oh!
Oh, stop it!
Guys!
Guys, where are you going?
I don't know!
Oh, you guys went the other way.
How do we get up there?
Um, there is it.
You have to go back to where we left off over here on the
other side.
And then you climb up.
It's raining, so I gotta take a second.
I got mega poison Oh my
We're like right here Okay I'm gonna eat my actually I'm not
eating anything yet Wait what's in your I'm gonna eat the
granola Wait it's for no buyer food?
I don't remember I'm just kidding Yeah hold on We're waiting
Where about did you go?
Oh I see you see the route Okay it's like this way And then
you climb like here Yeah I see We could just wait for the
poison to throw off.
That's fine.
Wait, this is a safe point.
Hi.
Oh my gosh.
You good?
There's a safe point on the edge.
You go there, then there.
Yeah, yeah.
That's that's fucky though.
Yeah, I can.
One percent time.
Ask me one percent time.
I don't know.
Okay, okay, okay, two people at a time.
All right, two people at a time, two people at a time, I
guess.
And then you go...
I'll just...
Oh, she's...
I'll just wait.
I think she's...
I think she's dead.
I'm here to lift you up, Min.
I think...
I think I...
I got you first!
I don't know if she can walk anymore.
What's in Min's backpack, Lim?
We might have to...
What?
We're gonna you three years of liability.
Oh, gotta wait for the rain.
Hold on.
We might have this we might have this the chain launcher
Make the chain, but we should keep it for the hard part.
Don't use it.
Don't use it now.
We need it for the other areas The other areas are more
important You hate fun You we have an hour left to make it
to the top the lobby just so you could get achievement We
gotta work for the achievements.
Oh, fuck.
I didn't help you here.
I hate this part.
I'm okay.
All right, and he just clabbed left.
You gotta do, like, some tap dancing.
Yeah, we got you.
Thank you.
We gotta help Mint.
Mint, I believe.
I believe in you.
All right, we're right here.
Yeah.
Nice.
Okay, I think we...
Yeah, it was so easy when there wasn't two people.
You might be able to walk around this way, too, but it could
be a bit slow.
There's, like, the Scoutmaster thing is right here.
wait who has item spots for the scout master thing there's a
bomb to our left so careful barely i'm kind of having it
yeah careful of the bomb yeah i say him this is so relaxing
i'll do like going outside who needs to touch who needs to
actually mount a glam when we can do this virtually
damn vision i don't remember what that does what's that
looks like a oh that's just the fall damage it protects you
from fall damage maybe that one oh and stamina oh shit with
stamina and fall damage so when you have it we can have
unlimited stamina but it's like oh my god i gotta put it in
my bag yeah yeah yeah sorry that was stamina not the fall
damage one enough room are you guys coming like this way or
should i go that way no no we're coming back that your way
that way is much easier okay i don't have enough room for
this but do you have room snuffy oh wait never mind i do
just kidding i do i do i'm a liar all right i need your hand
yep waiting waiting oh i used to my oh watch out watch out
watch out watch out okay um
What?
Who couldn't have?
Why am I a stowge?
Oh, that's the limiter.
The limiter.
Yeah, so the extra stamina that you can't get because of
the...
Oh, okay, okay.
Until the...
Until you make it to the campfire.
Dude, can the rain just stop for two seconds?
Doki, I need your hand.
Oh, never mind.
I'm good.
Thank you.
Yeah, I think that could do.
Yeah, it's a little bit sketchy, but I see at least two
places.
Yeah, I see like some areas.
It's so smooth sailing.
Nothing wrong could ever happen to us.
It's also inside which is nice because no rain.
Yeah.
Okay, let me check this out.
Thank you.
I'm scouting it.
It's a little weird.
There's a spot here too if we need it.
All right, I believe in Snuffy.
Snuffy's just gone for it.
Is there?
Yeah, yeah.
I would just go for it.
Just yolo it all right, and then I'll help up the next oh
you pick up the next person Thank you And then Oh, we're at
the top now you pick up the next person Wait, no, no, this
is not how we're the top.
Oh, hell yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, we just gotta make this jump
All right Thank you in case Did she make it to the top?
Is she oh wait, when somebody has their own path she has her
what she's making she's yeah this was so nice she
metacrafting okay right here coming right here and then this
should be the top thank you oh oh mushroom is that a good
mushroom that's a poison heal i think oh yeah it heals your
poison yeah it's good mushroom um okay i feel like we go
around right I feel like going around is, yeah.
Where's Snuffy going?
She's like meandering.
Oh, okay.
This way or up this way?
I mean, we could check.
Oh, this way is easier.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
100%.
Yeah.
I'm so miserly.
I'd like to like hoard food until the very last moment.
Help, thank you.
And then...
Oh, apparently it heals health down.
damage is well meant so I don't know if he took that much oh
yeah oh I just I didn't have enough space help oh sorry
thank you thank you thank you did I get you did I get you
why did you guys get each other yeah it's over there the
campfire is literally in front of us oh yeah we should have
done stuff these row was much easier but stuff is so good at
finding Yeah, unless you're for an item?
Um, where's the res?
No, we can do it now.
It's over here.
Yeah.
I'll pick it up.
I'm gonna eat.
Oh, well.
Oh, I'm gonna eat that.
This is a good item.
What's that?
Don't worry about it.
Make sure you cook things.
Oh, I forgot to cook it.
Don't worry about it.
Is there any food here?
There is.
There's a marshmallow.
Oh, marshmallow.
I have room in my backpack and won't put stuff in my
backpack.
Put this in my backpack.
Did Snuffy just go ahead and stay while waiting?
Stuffy?
Is she DC?
Push her off.
Push her off for her.
Are we...
Oh, wait.
Do we have lantern?
Oh, I think I did.
In my backpack.
Can you put this in mine?
Okay, so we're going to get the lantern later.
There you go.
ritual dagger what does that do don't worry about it all
right snuffy hurry up before we start getting hungry again
now i have the ritual dagger i'm gonna put that down you
don't know what you're doing welcome back are you ready tell
me what it does tell me what it does tell me what it does
i'll tell you what it does when the moment is right i'll
tell you what it does when the moment is right wait wait
wait wait put that drop that dagger drop that dagger down
Mint and mint drop where did you get a weapon tell me what
it does tell me what it does It's a friendship you don't
trust me no no it's a it's a I can't tell you when the
moment's right It's a it's like a destiny x back in the
dagger take her heart out.
It's a that's the x back Do you just get to get to X?
Yeah.
Snuffy, do it.
Snuffy, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, remember, we were, we were, we did
this together, Stuffy.
Wait, it doesn't do anything.
We did this together.
Stuffy, Stuffy, remember.
Wait, it doesn't do anything.
No, Stuffy, drop, drop the dagger.
Drop the dagger.
We were a team.
How do I use it?
Stuffy, we were a team, Stuffy.
We were a team.
Just do spot, you know?
Yeah.
Is this just like a CSGO like flip thing?
Just drop the dagger.
You don't know.
You don't know what you're doing with this.
I keep going.
I'm okay.
Where's, what's the do you say smocking apart?
What does that even mean?
If you're low on stamina, you can use it and get all your
stamina back.
Oh, I got all my stamina back.
Oh, so I cannibalized you.
yeah but now you lost the backpack that was holding the
others right here the backpack's right here but nobody has
enough inventory space to hold it now i i can use it oh i
have a fanny pack i can drop the fanny yeah what happened
what happened to the duo the dynamic duo stuffy what i said
don't do it somebody took my hot dog so i need it Somebody
took my hot dog.
It wasn't me.
I took my own hot dog.
There was no hot dog.
Sophie.
I thought we were the dynamic duo.
I thought we were a team.
You shouldn't tell me what it did.
I was going to tell you when the time is right.
The time was not right.
I thought you were like leaning on a joke.
Like you wanted it.
I appreciate that.
I feel safe around you.
I can't believe.
It would get me.
Hi.
What?
I helped so much during the last two.
How could you say that?
I say what that I feel safe around you how did you say that
you felt safe around everyone else but me live no I said I
feel safe around you guys how could you say yeah and I'm
dead I'm dead you say I think I think you might have a
little bit of a victim complex going on there because I said
I literally said I feel safe around you and I didn't feel
like you were gonna die for me why didn't you say before I
died why didn't you say it before I died why did you say it
before I died why is say it after I die.
Not the way for you guys to make it all the way up top
there.
That's what the dagger actually does, I think.
Endless ducky yap mechanic.
Yeah.
Some people would kill for that.
I'm so sad.
Oh, no.
We'll revive you at the next part.
I can't believe.
I can't believe you stabbed in the back.
I had so much stamina.
Why are you talking to me?
I didn't do anything.
I think Doki's leaving.
You took the knife out of my backpack.
It started the store.
And then she's telling it meant about getting stabbed, but
you stabbed her.
She took...
She was the starting point.
I'm getting victim blamed here.
Oh, you're blaming the...
You're victim blaming me right now.
You guys, there's a jetpack here.
If only we had a fourth backpack.
I've only...
Oh, man.
If only something did happen to me.
me.
I'm gonna drop this item.
There's another jetpack.
Oh.
What does this even mean?
It's just a jetpack, but you can't wear it with your
backpack, though.
Oh, you can't wear it with a backpack either?
No, you can't.
You have to, or a Fanny pad.
Like, you can only wear one thing.
Oh my god!
I'm a ghost.
Ooh.
I can't get cold.
This is not warm.
No, you guys just huddle up.
Huddle up.
Come here.
Cuddle up.
If only there was a fourth person to huddle up with.
Oh dear.
If only.
You're fine.
Make sure to pick your items up.
Oh okay.
Anybody wants to die?
Don't forget the ending item.
We should move.
I got it.
Who has the other ending item?
I thought Doki had.
Did Doki have it?
It's in my backpack.
Oh okay.
food while you guys do this oh my i'm so sorry look at this
thing you said that's what i did i said when the time is
right you guys just couldn't i wanted to build up suspense i
was trying to build up suspense i needed to know now i'm
scared around why were you scared oh i'm good i don't need
it oh okay okay yeah Thanks, though.
It was a narrative device!
Uh, do you have one for an energy drink?
No.
Uh-huh.
I could get rid of some ropes that I have.
Is it getting foggy?
Oh, get inside, get inside.
Yeah, we're kind of on the edge of the map.
Just huddle up.
I'm coming.
Drop down here as well.
You get out of the cold.
Yeah, there we go.
Oh.
Definitely in the cold.
A little bit.
Okay, we're good.
I should have put it.
I should have put the dagger in my hands, not in my
backpack.
I should have put it in my...
I should have kept it in my hands.
Little did I know it would be the death of me.
This game is so cruel.
Why would you want to kill your teammates?
It's like cannibalism.
It's basically the cannibalism mechanic.
But why would they start?
Yeah, because so if we are dying, each other to survive i
might need a hand up they left me where are you see lamb i
wouldn't have left you where are you i would have given my
hand i'm in the bottom of the pit oh okay i'm coming oh here
you are wait oh hi can i walk along here thank you you know
for if you're down there too you guys yes you can i was down
there and i keep her a moral support moral support thank you
yeah i think i mean the route's not bad i see a lot of like
places you can climb right now you can scout for us toky oh
no i'm huddled huddled share your body if your clothes are
wet you should take out your clothes so it won't be as wet
i'm on top of you guys don't worry about it oh yeah What's
the order for dinner, guys?
Kind of cuisine.
Dumplings.
Dumplings?
That's what I have for dinner.
I'm hungry.
Wait, dumplings are nice.
Maybe sushi?
Sushi?
Sushi, sushi.
Sushi's always good.
I'm going around this way.
It looks easy.
I don't get dumplings.
I've had, uh, actually depends on how the dumplings, though.
I feel like they're so...
to death it they travel so well you know thank you thank you
sushi travels well too because it's not like it can get cold
that's true but i had sushi two days i had sushi two days
ago it could be gross so i'm like probably dumplings nobody
wants sushi don't really want sushi just because i had it
two days ago oh i kind of want sushi i like variety huddle
huddle we're in the It's not helping!
We got to get out of it!
We guys have to find the headmaster's thing too later.
Yeah, where's the thing?
I don't see it.
I saw it a while ago.
I didn't see it.
Because I was dead.
Just saying.
You could scout for it, you know.
Oh, it's in front of you guys.
It's literally in front of you guys.
Hey, I see it.
Look at that.
I helped.
Is this the last stage?
No, there's one more.
Uh, there's the gloom.
The gloom is...
There's some berries over there.
Hold on.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, my Lord.
Wait for me.
I'm grabbing a berry.
I'm following you, Lymu.
Thanks.
Follow you to the end.
Loyal to the end.
Oh, it's orange.
I don't know.
Is orange safe?
Orange is safe.
It's safe.
I think it, like, warmed you up or something.
It is safe.
I remember.
It's like, because it's a tangerine.
Like a little owl.
for you guys delicious you should be fine oh there's another
one oh oh oh i got it i got it thank you i'm gonna get curry
i hope everything is good may i have it yeah i'll feed it to
you thank you see how close you're thank you oh stuffy might
need not she's not really needing food but if you guys find
food yeah i can see your stats yeah you can see your stats
when they're dead me oh okay i still am thriving off of
dokey's life can you can you put a handout oh it's not what
it decrees is out of the winter is always kind of bullshit
how is this not working yes oh i got it it's because the
blizzard stopped the blizzard stopped so you guys can keep
climbing yeah green curry oh right i do oh green curry's
nice yeah green curry medium spice does it come on curry
that's great spice why yeah oh there's some more fruit here
snuffy if you want some yeah yeah snuffy needs the fruit
snuffy come here i'll feed you uh okay oh wait i'm feeding
you i should thank you i can see here the fans being like
that should have been me not her along here maybe yeah yeah
green curry oh why is everything sparkling purple it was
doing it in the first area too oh it's sparkling purple oh i
don't know yeah i think it might be like it would work it
works here but in the first area it's still doing it all the
time look at that tree whoa would be the textures magical i
can't wait for christmas Please, please.
You know what would be great Christmas presents?
Oh, come down here.
Come back down here.
Sloppy fans is the Gina Draws merchandise collab.
That would be a great birthday gift, a great Christmas gift,
a great Valentine's Day gift, a great anniversary gift.
It's good for your first 40 children as well.
Yeah, yeah, buy as an investment for your grandkids, too.
No, your grandma would love a cardigan.
And your grandma.
Your grandparents, grandma, parents.
It's a gift for everybody.
has the best cardigan for a grandma or so it's like right
above you guys we care about the blue the blue um i just
think a grandma would look the cutest in yours that's so
true though oh okay you could maybe we don't try maybe do
the left side and then drop down over here over here maybe
yeah yeah oh my god that was a loud thump Dump.
Dump.
I'm thumping.
Thump.
Okay, yeah, this is much better.
Whoa, wait, what's that?
What's that over there?
There's something like red and...
So the messed up rocks, they will icy.
I don't know what the purple is.
Oh, that?
Oh, yeah.
It's a bad touch.
Evil aura.
It's probably not good.
What evil?
Oh, yeah, I see.
It's some sort of cursing.
climbing inside here which is weird because you think like
climbing inside or sorry outside is fucking enough they both
kind of suck it's gonna it's gonna wind blast us right here
i bet you wait so we can't touch this guy yeah you can but
you'll freeze yeah you'll keep me like frozen okay it like
gives you like was it permanent stat debuff or what was it
temporary same as the blizzard oh i hate you game oh come on
help shut up oh wait wait wait wait stop here come back I
don't know.
Oh, no, I'm not.
No, you're good.
You're good.
I think it's stopped now.
It's going to stop soon, the Blizzard.
You don't have to waste it all.
No, I'm still accumulating slightly.
Yeah, I was still accumulating too.
Yeah, but then the Blizzard was going to stop soon, so
they'll like die down anyway.
That looks kind of.
Thank you, wise ghost.
Is there a response to this thing?
Yes, I got it.
Could you put a hand down for me?
She lost all her stamina for this, by the way.
I'm so okay.
Thank you.
Oh, dear.
Who me?
Yeah, you have no stamina.
You don't have extra stamina anymore.
Yeah, I know.
I've been hoarding mine since the start.
Yeah, I had maxed it.
I had maxed it too, guys.
Yeah.
You know, you could technically could have pulled a dagger
out and kept it.
It worked again?
Yeah, it's like multiple use.
What's that do?
I don't know.
That was the the shield i think the tenacity yeah the other
one was a shield i think no the other one's stamina this one
i don't have space though one of you guys have to you have
to keep all of it to uh for the trending i have one space in
my backpack now if you guys want to put it in there yeah
okay yeah put that in there i don't know the red after what
do the balloons do the balloons make you climb high, it
floats you up so you can climb higher.
Left side, there is a there might be a route left side,
Limeo.
There's a good spot here, but I don't know how to get there.
There is a left side, if I could wait, wait, wait, there's a
gap, go forward.
There's a gap in the whole Lime.
You climb up that?
Like here?
Yeah, climb that up and you can see a gap.
I see it.
Oh, and there's a box of stuff.
Look at that!
There's two boxes.
It's a jackpot!
I hope they have weed in here.
Oh, what?
Wait, and it gives you slow fall so you don't get flow
damage, you're it.
Oh, do you need this, man?
Are you hungry or are you good?
I don't know the route after that, guys.
Oh, you took it.
How'd you take it from me?
Oh, you didn't pick it up.
Do you need it?
Do you want me to pick it up now, actually?
Yeah, I'll meet it then.
Wait, Stuffy, you don't need the binoculars, by the way.
You can throw the binoculars.
Stuffy!
No!
But not!
I'm sorry!
It wouldn't let me grab you.
I was holding an item.
Sophie, you can throw away the binoculars.
There's no use for it.
I just like to look.
Okay, I got my handle for you, man.
We need the inventory space.
Got you.
I'm sorry for failing you.
The rocks to your left.
It's okay.
It's not the first time.
I'm full left.
Wow!
Here?
Yeah, I mean there's no other way.
You have to go to the left side.
This isn't this is not a great no that doesn't look great.
You don't oh there's no clampable spot.
I think we might have to use the chain to go to the left
side.
I have rope also.
How do we how did we end up here?
There's no other way though.
That's the thing.
Do you still have the chain?
Yeah, I have it.
Chain launcher?
It kind of looks like this should be but it's not.
It's I don't know.
Do I just shoot that other rock out?
Or what do I shoot?
Like here?
Like the one on the rocks there and then climb across it.
I guess it's not.
All right, here I go.
I believe in you.
Well, not that one.
Well, I wasn't.
That's what Sophie was pointing to.
I believe in myself.
That might be slightly fucked.
Well, but we're seeing it again.
I don't think that was.
Oh, no.
I don't.
Lime is it manageable?
Hold up.
Oh, it's not.
Oh my god.
Oh, no.
Stuffy, what did you do?
I'm full of good ideas.
Okay.
It's not that people have no stamina.
There's no...
Min's not going to make it.
Min's not going to make that.
She has no stamina.
What do you mean?
Stuffy, what did you do?
If you can get to Get to this, get to the near point and
then jump here.
I think that's the only way.
I don't get, I have more stamina than Lymo.
Wait, no, no, no, you have no stamina, Mint.
You have no stamina.
I think one of you guys have to use the balloons at this
rate because one of you might not make it.
Mint, take the balloons.
I'm gonna, no, I'm gonna eat.
I'm gonna eat.
One of you is not gonna make it.
Wait, no, no, no, no.
Mint can use her ram.
Use the ram and use it to climb.
use the ram what's the ram the ram is unlimited your
artifact oh okay okay you eat that eat that use the ram and
climb the chain don't use it now don't use it now though
like use it when you're at the chain and then use it and
then climb and then stuff you have to climb with her because
it's unlimited stamina for both of you if you're in the
vicinity okay can she use it while she's holding Yeah, yeah,
three.
It's time, hold on.
No, no, no, no, you can't use it.
It's time, it's time.
So like, she used it and then you climb.
This is a life or death mission right now.
This is the final countdown.
We're going to do it.
Do a countdown and then you have to rush it.
Okay, all right.
Three, two, one.
Go, go, go, go, climb, climb, climb.
Men, jump down.
Men!
Why was I on it?
Jumped in here!
What if we just go up though?
You can do that if you want!
Okay, sure!
I'll need help!
Wait, I have a rope!
Why was I on it?
Because you have to jump up the edge for it!
I did!
I climbed!
Sophie, do you have any of the...
Do you have any of the artifacts on you?
I need to know.
Um, no.
Okay, alright.
So, okay, okay, if you have to die, it's okay.
That's fair.
Wait, I have an idea.
Okay, you guys might have to leave stuff.
You might have to leave stuffy.
She is very far.
Oh, man, you cannot die because you have all the artifacts.
You have to live.
You actually just have to live.
I'm extending the road.
Why do I use the balloon?
Mint is very cold, by the way.
Mint is very cold.
There is a rope in front of you, but that's the extent it
will go.
Wait, I'm gonna lower the rope for you.
Wait, I don't know if you should come up here, Lai Vu.
You had...
Oh.
Oh, it's all going to pieces.
No, it's fine.
It's fine.
I'm gonna go up.
Mint, stop.
Lai Vu's here.
Lai's here.
Oh.
I'm yeah, I'm fine.
Is she okay?
She's okay.
All right I'm doing you gotta figure out the route for her I
she has all the artifacts she could also use the ramp one
more time To make it okay.
Yeah, yeah, okay.
Yeah, yeah, I actually have them.
I'm sorry Wait, what did I fall from here?
Oh, shoot.
Oh no, not good not good.
Not good Oh, no, no, no, no.
Mim, don't climb don't climb.
Stay there.
Just stay with Lyme.
Just huddle up with Lyme.
Yeah, no go with me.
No go with me.
Just don't leave.
Just huddle up.
Just stay to get it.
Stay to get it.
Just huddle.
I'm trying.
I'm not touching anything.
Okay, Mint is... Mint's gonna pass out.
Mint's gonna pass out.
She has the RFID!
No!
I wasn't stabbed!
What do you get again?
What do you fucking mean again?
Fuck you game?
Man.
I'm dead.
Two fucking storms.
Some of you are the only one left.
Some of you...
I barely left.
I'm basically like a walking corpse.
What does the turtle artifact even do?
It's fall damage.
Mint?
Yeah?
No, I'm not alive.
Yeah, I am.
Mint is barely alive.
She is barely alive.
She...
I don't even know.
Oh, my God.
Wait, Mint.
Okay.
You both have artifacts on you, right?
Both of you guys.
You have three, right?
Yep.
Do you have a med kit stuffy?
There's one there.
No, I don't have any heels or anything.
Okay.
Well...
What's even it?
In my inventory.
Oh, it's so far.
Right.
The full...
If you go full right, there's a route.
You see it?
Oh, I don't think guys can make it.
I don't think you guys can make it.
No, no, no, no.
Never mind.
Don't do that route.
Don't do that.
You guys are not going to make that route.
I'm frozen.
Oh.
Stop.
It doesn't stop.
I'll get over the poison eventually.
Oh.
Oh my god.
This could be good.
Wait, this could be good, Doki.
I'll get over it eventually.
Is Limeu excelling?
No, no.
Limeu's gone.
She's gone, gone.
Now she's gone.
Okay, you go left.
Go left side for the route.
The route is left.
Wait, what else is going to do?
You just gotta wait.
Min has to wait.
Min has to wait because the poison's still there.
You have to wait.
Oh, okay.
I'm like half the...
just stay stay there with her she's gone lime there's no
coming back from lime all right so what you can do okay so
you do have the grapple gun okay if mint dies or mint needs
help you can grapple her to you oh really i could have
caught her in midair dang it i didn't know okay so oh it
hurt so bad what if you had missed though what if you had
missed well if she missed she'd see you you could okay
stuffy could do the hell mary pick up all the artifacts and
just use a grapple gun to get up top that's like literally
like the grapple gun isn't long enough i've been trying to
use it wait help me help me help me yeah i don't we're okay
we're okay what's this lamu you're i don't think you're
making it lamu you're i saw you falling 10 stories down
what's it else is in your i'm not that i got i got some
chain but But the mist is going to take me, I think.
Oh, yeah, you're dead soon.
I got three back-to-back storms.
What was that about?
That was crazy.
Okay, so go up.
You go up from here.
Okay, go up here.
Go up from here and then use the chain.
I don't know if I can make this.
Wait, can we make the chain?
Can you make it up there?
Yeah, that's pretty tough.
You might have to...
I think I can make it and lift up a rope for mint.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, I don't think I can make it.
Oh, shoot.
So I just let yourself recharge.
Okay, so what, you have to use the ram again.
I think.
I think it's just ram time.
I don't have it anymore.
What did you do?
Oh, it must have fell off of your body.
I think it fell off of my body when I've dropped.
We don't even have it anymore.
We don't even have it.
We know.
Wait, maybe.
R&D foot.
If we had the dagger, we could stab one of us to make it to
the top.
Oh my god, you didn't see the ram on your way up here, did
you?
Yeah, you didn't see the ram down there, did you?
Unfortunately not.
No true ending, unfortunately.
No.
I took both of those for nothing.
Well, I still have the turtle if anybody doesn't want to
fall down.
Okay.
That's fun.
Oh, look, we're back at the chain.
I thought we'd try and go a different way around, because
that was cursed maybe this way like if we just go back the
way we came then you know the same thing's gonna happen
again thank you all I come okay honestly I mean this looks I
remember that we tried to do the right side but you guys
couldn't make the jump that's the thing well no that was
that was back where I fell I used a chain launcher to skip
it yeah yeah we already sidetracked the like the wrong way
off the route I guess this might be this might be cookie.
That's what I'm saying.
Like, you guys can't make it that jump.
A body down there?
What is this?
Oh, is that where we Oh, is that the thing?
That's where we got the thing.
Yeah, that's where you're, that's the scout master.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
There's nothing up there, by the way.
Stuffy.
Oh, okay.
We need to get here, but I don't know if we can.
No, we couldn't, because Stuffy tried that last time.
Oh.
Can we?
If we had the chain, we could.
but we don't have a chain right now i had to use the chain
to get here unfortunately we could climb through the cave
it'll be though yeah i think that's our only option though
it is yeah we don't have a lot of items left now i'm scared
i know right i was relaxed now i don't like it i don't know
if we can make it through the cave this looks too i hate the
inside bro i don't think We could go round more to the right
and hope there's a path up.
There may be.
What do you guys have in your backpacks anymore?
Snuffy, you're going to fall.
You're going to fall.
You keep going.
Guys, we're going to lose Snuffy.
Oh, no.
Why are we going to lose Snuffy?
No, it's fine.
Never mind.
Oh, my God.
They never.
I don't know where to go after that, though, Snuffy.
You're way too deep in there.
I'm going for the cursed Archer.
Snuffy, I'm gonna need a hand up if I fall or yeah.
Oh my god.
I don't know if that's a good idea It's blood.
It's too late.
I'm not making it.
You're not making it.
Lamo.
I'm sorry She's gonna make it.
She's gonna make it.
I'm not gonna make it.
You're not gonna make it.
I think you guys might have to split up Mint and I don't
even want to deceive but the Hail Mary doing cursed artifact
would help us This sucks you guys will have to split up
because you and you and Mint don't have the same stamina as
a snuffy okay i'm gonna get killed by wind she's not injured
i did that too that happened to me also we died together
yeah i got hit by three windstorms in a row it was such can
you make this oh my god what is that what is this i don't
know i've never seen that before napa berry I've never
seen...
Oh.
I guess that's what it does.
No!
Oh my crap!
Like, items just fall!
That was so sticky!
No.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I don't!
Oh!
Dang it.
Okay, where's gang?
Oh, you okay?
You good.
I'm just gonna drop it down.
What's good?
All right.
They went down-ish, so I don't know.
I think, Stuffy, you're on your own, Stuffy.
You're on your own in this class.
I'm so screwed.
Stuffy, was it worth stabbing me, Stuffy?
Was it worth stabbing?
No, no.
Why did you tell me?
What's the word?
Why didn't you wait?
Sophie, why didn't you wait?
It was a, I set up a narrative device for us.
A narrative device that would come up later on when the time
is right.
What's this?
Is this fine?
After everything we've been- That was all fair.
I don't know where I am I'm in
I'm okay I'm okay everything is fine everything in La La
Land is awesome and epic nothing just died in this hole
nothing just died in the hole this is your grave this is
your grave this is karma we're killing your friend you die
in the dark hole alone where's my epic awesome kingdom where
does it even fall to at least i died surrounded with my
friend stuffy you will die alone in darkness goodbye stuffy
said oh stuffy said she's she's she's her she made her own
funeral in the dark and scary hole she made her own grave
how did that happen she's gone now you can hear her voice
something i mean you called me dead a while ago and i wasn't
no no she's no she is very very much dead there's no
returning is that a good route man okay
you might hear like the echoes of her crying but that's just
the echoes of her screams yeah but that's just any any more
pathways or do you know do you need me to move around oh
shoot oh shoot um that feels like you should be able to
stand on it I could just hear her talking to herself.
Those dashes post-death screams, like the echoes of her
soul.
Oh, I see.
Oh, this is flaky.
Oh, not again.
Oh, wouldn't it be the left side?
You see the left side?
The left side.
Min, can you wait for me?
I need to come back around where you are.
No, I meant like there's a route to your left.
Look to your left.
Like, this?
Yeah, push where it was.
Oh, I was going to say there was like...
There's like...
There's a couple, but I don't know where to go after that.
I mean, I could just scale all the way.
Oh, shit.
Because I don't know if you can do anything from where you
are now.
That's the thing.
Yeah, this looks fucked.
I don't know about this.
This might be a trick.
This is a trick.
Yeah.
That's why I'm thinking, like, the left side might be your
best bet.
Like, here?
Yeah, you jump over into that rock over there.
Oh, my God.
Do you see the fog?
It's coming.
Do you see me?
as mid i've had to go left i think you have to leave her
like i see the i see the top almost now and then just res
everybody yeah lamb you just have to go and res everybody at
this point hopefully i think you might make it there's an
item to your right mid she left you for dead i told her to
come back for you and then i told her don't follow me
Wait!
No!
I'm sorry!
Yeah, I'm definitely not making it now.
What?
Wait, little boy!
Lay me!
Oh, thanks.
I'm so glad you didn't even like find the place.
I survived, I survived.
Donky, you keep saying people die and then they live.
I wouldn't hide in here.
Don't, if you saw what I I saw.
There's no way she should have lived.
What happened?
We're gonna make it to the top, dookie.
We're gonna make it to the top.
You didn't believe in me.
And here we are succeeding.
To your right.
If you go to the right, there's...
Go to the right.
To the right.
There's luggage.
There's also...
Stop it!
I can hear snuffy declaring me dead as as as like I was
lying at the bottom like recovering I don't know how she
lived I legitimately don't know how she did it no no no no I
don't know she had like no no I don't even know how she
survived no there's no reason for her to be alive I to your
left maybe we can't slow down the fog is coming yeah we
gotta go we gotta go look for items maybe to your left is
anybody hungry is anybody hungry to your life if you jump
and then get that and then climb left there's there's like a
bunch of areas to climb oh gosh thank you mm-hmm thank you
and then you creep oh what the what was that if I use a heat
pack does it heal the heat or prevent it or both prevents it
okay and heals it maybe okay and then I have no idea how she
lived i legit you were you were you broke half your body so
close the fog is so close you gotta go okay you have to go
left and then jump there and then you would be up the top
there you climb that up like climb up that and then climb
come here come here come here i'm coming you guys have to
you guys have to can't keep keep stalling anymore you have
to keep climbing this this way this way this way around the
left around the left yeah yeah get your stamina jump to your
left Oh, you guys are using your stamina, though.
All right, and then stuffy just climbed that.
This is like a backseat, or literally, like...
All right, do you need my help or not?
Do you need...
Do you need me to scout out the mountains or not?
Guys.
You sound like my cat.
Oh, the Pythagoras!
The Pythagoras!
Yay!
All right, give me your peace.
All right, and then you gotta climb up from here.
is literally right below you so yes just clap going going
okay wait recharge stamina you recharge stamina oh what oh
you could recharge your stamina stuffy before you did that
okay yeah oh no we're in the fog we're in the fog yeah
that's what I'm saying you have to recharge your stamina and
then oh my god stuffy you guys are gonna make is this is
this is there a spot up here yes there is there is there is
if you guys make it there is oh okay you make it this is not
a spot to stand what do you mean it is it was a spot it was
a spot you have to leave them you have to leave them they're
not making it they're not here that's not here they're not
go label down they're not making it you have to go you have
to go you have to go they're not making it just i could have
put rope with the fog and the fucking wind oh this this way
What do you mean too at a row?
Oh no.
Oh, okay.
Oh, I got it.
Oh, I have this.
I have this.
Quickly, quickly.
Snuffy.
How do I use it?
How do I use it on the wall?
Mounted on the wall.
Wait, Snuffy, take it.
Snuffy, take it.
Ermine.
It's over for me.
Where did you put it?
It's in my hand.
Oh, I'll drop it.
Wait, where I can, there we go.
There you go.
Take it.
Okay.
Go.
yeah baton it you have baton it now you have baton it now
you have baton it now no no it only you're like you're baton
i'm trying i'm trying you're baton king white baton baton
baton baton okay baton baton baton you have to climb it's
freezing it's freezing you have to climb
no it only helps if you're like it's high up right yeah
By the way, she made it to the top so you guys can die now.
Limo made it to the top, you said?
Yeah, made it to the top, yeah.
Oh.
Did she actually?
How do I...
We were so close.
It's okay, Limo made it for us.
No.
Did she actually...
Yeah, she made it.
That's definitely that's right.
It didn't matter.
You still die in the end, Zuffy.
You still die in the end.
It's because you don't lie when you abandon us, you guys!
You see it.
That was the literary device that...
I get to use my narrative device now.
God, God, God, God!
What the?
What is that?
That's her dead body.
Alright, I'm just waiting for Min to die and then I can
raise you all.
I just need to wait.
We just need to wait for Min to die.
You could have saved this, but Doki sabotaged us all!
She said to leave us behind!
I mean, in fairness, I was taking cold damage.
Yeah, so my advice was the good advice.
And the fog was like...
Man, we need you to just...
Just keep using it, you turn it into stone.
Just keep using it.
Oh, okay.
Use it again, and again, and again.
see i see bye i'm stone i kind of think you knew it was
gonna do that hi i think it was gonna hi all right let me
arrest you it's okay i thought maybe it would just debuff
her like it was very clearly not gonna debuff her because
she's been here for cagey about what if he does
device, guys.
Oh my god, my scout's generosity.
Or, wait, no, this is the other one.
Man, we only have one of those.
Yeah, it was the one that I brought.
I figured we didn't need it much anymore.
Is there any food for me, though?
No.
You just came back.
Do you need food?
Yeah, I'm hungry.
Doki took it.
There was only one sausage.
There was only... I deserve I deserve it.
I got stabbed.
I got I got stabbed.
Wait, can you use the thing to dupe it?
Dupe the sausage with the gem.
I already ate it.
You already fucking ate it.
I was hungry.
I could have probably made it because that thing healed me,
but Doki told me to kill myself.
She promotes bad behaviors.
I was not the one that got stabbed.
Snuffy, do you have the dupe talisman?
So the thing about this area is that the fog will make you
tired.
That's the thing.
I'm already tired.
I'm tired of the shing.
That's really sickening.
God, this place is ass.
Is this instead of the kiln or in addition to?
Um, no, after this is the citadel.
So this is the second last.
So what are your crows?
This is so doky.
So the crow, the crow will mimic our voices.
So it'll make it so that we don't know where we are when
we're in the fog.
When we're in the fog, we won't know where we are.
Like where each person is.
so it'll sound like it'll sound like if i'm behind you the
crows will make it sound like i'm in front of you i honestly
think the audio in this game is confusing anyway so it is
quite all right so we should grab some suitcases because
we're so fucked up right now i'm extraordinarily fucked up
like i'm so messed up that i might as well just give my life
for the cause right now uh you can give your life for the
cause when you know we're getting close to death Yeah, I
might be the goodie reply.
I am close to death.
I am.
All right, let's go forward.
I just rose.
I'll be close to death.
I hit my phone.
All right, we got to make, we got to rush it.
Make a B-line.
All right, who wants to lead?
Well, that's the most stamina.
I guess Lymo does.
I have a lot.
I'm going to go straight here.
I'm going to get my marshmallow.
Because there's a, you go straight?
Well, I guess not.
I guess I'll accidentally fell down.
Whatever.
If you do an echo, have fun.
I wonder if the bird's hard enough.
So do we have to go through, we have to go through the mist.
Yes.
Oh, there's little men pointing.
Are the men pointing the best route?
Yeah, the men.
I don't know.
Bully?
I made it.
Oh, fuck.
I hurt my little shins.
Oh, it's a clown bag.
Alright, right here.
I didn't realize it was gonna be so deep once you jump down.
Yeah.
Oopsie daisy.
Yeah, alright.
There's gonna be banana.
peels and stuff so careful there's banana peels i don't know
something yeah there is one over there all right if anyone
has food i could really use it we don't have i got fortified
milk we have to go this way we have to go straight my
sausage sadly what is what do you mean your sausage it was
only i'm going for it there's a there's a pathway here i'm
going for it right now
I have bandages.
You can actually go around without touching the thing.
Yeah, but we need this, though.
I'm hearing snoring or crows.
It's crows.
Alright.
Oh, crows.
We have to go.
Oh, this is hard.
I don't know about this route.
Oh, there's eggs here.
I think you can eat the eggs.
If you eat it.
That's food.
That's food, Mint.
Wait, we lost Limeo.
Put an extra in my bag.
We lost stuffy.
Okay.
We did.
I don't know if she went.
it because it won't let me eat it i'm bad i think you have
to smash it i had like one hps i just fell asleep oh my god
okay hold on all right i'm gonna need a lift up dokey oh i
need an arm thank you thank you i'm coming down all right
okay there's fall damage careful
jc see that it sounded like she was i heard the crow thanks
all right so we could try it's not like meant to me yeah
yeah so we could try and go here or we i don't think we can
make it across from there though no right i mean let's yeah
go there i want to go all right
okay we make up here just go straight
okay and then you good you good yeah good job good job
everybody okay this is where it it gets a little fucky.
We can go here and then there's a box here at least.
Yeah, there's a box over there.
I would grab that before we go.
And then we go back this way, I think.
Well, one of you guys can grab it then.
And then I'll wait here.
I'll go to that side right now and wait.
What was in there?
Okay, we have to go.
Mint, you have to come back from here.
Mint, come back this way.
Come back, Mint.
From the away so we can go to this tree.
I don't think we're going to make it to Isha to Sidat out.
I think you just have to fucking book it up.
We give you every resource possible and you just fucking run
up.
At this point, I don't know if you've been there.
I don't think it's...
I don't think all of us are going to make it.
Despite everything we did, снимus still carried us as far as
we got.
I believe in us.
We tried to fight the timeline, and it was inevitable.
Who was the ghost?
go the future that got stabbed stuffy i couldn't well that's
gonna kill me and i wouldn't have killed you i was setting
up a narrative device i was said i was setting up don't get
mad that the narrative device played out i was the betrayer
the ultimate betrayer all right let's see oh hey uh mint
what was in the this way mint you got it yeah you got it
okay a ghost saying which way in your voice it's very
confusing oh really yeah this is a very long trek over here
there's a gate below it all right i'll hold you okay well
the candle will be good but don't not don't use it now don't
use the candle now we have to keep it at one more closer
because they're all right because it basically gets rid of
all the sleep all right let's go let's go let's go go go go
oh out i do have a bandage if we need it later i have a
little bit of damage i do too mint is gonna fall asleep oh
she'll be no she's not she's gonna be great you're gonna do
fine you're gonna do fine min you're gonna do fine all right
i got you i'm gonna go for there's oh yeah was there was
there another crate oh there's a crate here we should just
it's here and then here we should we should hop across these
little ones yeah guys i'm not gonna make it what you are
gonna make it you're gonna make it you're gonna make it i'm
hungry you're gonna make it you're gonna make okay i've got
another candle give me the candle mint mint mint do you need
another egg oh my god mint mint she's so brave she's so
brave she did the impossible a sports drink okay oh my gosh
is pokari do you want to put the sports drink in my bag or
do you want to use it now i think i'll drink wait she should
eat the egg instead no hold on give me the sports drink in
my bag and i'll give you an egg get the egg because the egg
will I'm hungry.
Put the sports drink in my bag and I give you egg.
Here, egg.
Smash it on the ground.
Wait, how'd you do that?
Throw it hard.
Eat it.
There you go.
Eat the egg.
We could have duplicated it.
Oh my god, we could have duplicated the egg.
I've got two more eggs.
We're fine.
That's good.
Oh, that's how, all right.
I thought you only had one egg.
Wait, you only had one egg.
I have two.
Oh!
This is- Ah!
Help!
What is that?
Run!
Use the cattle!
Okay, I'm okay, I'm okay, okay, okay.
Okay, I don't have a cattle!
Don't use it.
We're fine.
So there are plants that will eat you.
It really matches your outfit.
You look so sleepy.
There are plants.
There are plants that will...
Do we go this way for the chest or do we go this way?
I think we just...
We go here and then we go here and then here.
I need a heal.
I won't make it.
I think I have enough stamina to go get the crate.
I think you go get the crate then.
Min and I will stick together.
I do not have enough to...
Oh, Mint.
I can't go up there.
Mint.
This is not looking good.
You should...
Oh, no!
My cruel world!
Goodbye!
Min has the candle.
Min, she's gone, bro.
Use the candle, Min!
Use the candle!
Okay, don't turn it off.
Turn the candle off.
Cat, turn it off!
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, okay.
She's so serious about it.
Dude, use your big cannon.
Shoot yourself, shoot yourself now.
What the fuck?
Doki, I have a candle for you.
Okay, no, no, it's fine.
I'll heal from the poison.
Alright, I'm doing it.
Oh my god, you're crazy, you're crazy.
I told you you should have used the can the cannon dude I'm
gonna make it Oh, oh, I'm gonna make it.
I'm gonna make it.
I knew it.
Oh dang.
Okay.
All right No, I don't understand.
I got eaten alive by that miss.
It's just not fair.
This game is bad From here.
It's pretty there's a there's a rope we could climb but Is
that pretty bad What's this what's this where you going
don't you're off you you pass it you pass it it's to your
right you're going backwards uh she's lost she's lost i'm
here i'm here i'm here i'm here i just don't i see the light
you see the light over there what is that we doesn't do
anything for us anymore to follow the i want to follow the
light don't follow the light don't follow the light though
don't follow the light you guys are gonna go and then go
straight oh wait actually i need another egg i need
Duplicate the egg?
Yeah, we have to duplicate it.
Who has it?
Mint has it.
Duplicate the egg.
Mint.
What is it, is it the generosity?
I'm also hungry, so please duplicate the egg.
How do you, how do you do it?
You cover it, and then you do this.
Okay.
Hey, egg.
All right.
Did you get one, Lymo?
I did not get one.
Okay, I'll drop it and I'll duplicate it again.
Okay.
Thank you.
All right.
We will download an egg.
Do we go this one?
Is that clamor?
That's a long way.
Oh, there's a little...
Do you want to try this thing here?
Do you see this little island?
I mean, we have to use the candle at that point.
We have two, right?
The candle will not be useful for the Citadel, so we have to
use one of them now.
What does the candle do exactly?
We won't get tired.
We'll start walking.
Just one is fine.
One is fine.
And then we'll start walking.
Okay, you get yours.
All right, start walking, and then we'll use it when we're
midway.
Okay.
All right.
Why does it do that sometimes?
Oh, right here.
It's an island.
I think they'll hear me the other way, though.
No, I'm here.
I'm here.
Okay, you're here.
All right, we don't have to use it then.
You're over there.
No, I'm not here.
Does the fog climb in this level?
I'm assuming not because it's flat.
No, no, no, no.
It's behind us.
The fog is behind us.
Oh, it's behind us.
All right, this way then.
It's slowing down.
Go, team!
Oh, there's one of those plants.
I don't know.
I don't trust any of them.
I'm snoring.
We're doing great.
Yeah, this one's not the way.
We can book it to the center, right?
We go here.
That's a long fucking way to book it.
I mean, we can go here.
We have to go here.
Yeah.
Okay.
We can make that easy.
All right, Mint, just get ready with your candle if we need
it.
Okay.
Oh, shit.
Oh, froggy.
A frog?
They're not kill you.
Ah!
Why did you say that?
Hey, what's the early worm do?
You can eat it.
I can eat it.
Everybody's good.
Take it.
There's another.
The early worm is in there.
It's fine.
We don't need it.
Early worm?
The bird?
I think we can use the candle.
just to get over here, just to get there.
Because the candle does not make, we don't need the candle
in the citadel.
I think we could just, yeah.
Thank you.
Just use the candle, yeah.
Use your candle, go, go, go, just use it now.
And then we go straight.
Watch out for frogs.
Oh, the frogs are dangerous.
Oh, candles low, candles low.
We have Lyman's candle.
Lyman prepare second candle.
Yeah, prepare second candle.
it or five soonish wait oh my gosh this sucks uh now now
used wait where are you guys you're so coordinated wait are
we going the right way split up liva was away from you guys
her candle's not affecting you anymore no oh no i think we
went the wrong way liva we went the wrong way fuck i didn't
need to abandon then we just got lost in the reeds oh i
think why did I follow why did I guys I followed mid I
followed mid why did I follow you why did I follow you why
every time you all you could do is I catch only are you
there why wait oh no oh my god nice really nice you with the
Is it direction?
That was legendary.
And I got you there.
Rested.
Oh, she's still lost though.
Yeah, where are you, Doki?
Where am I?
Is there a direction point before they kill or the thing?
Was it at all?
What the hell happened to you guys?
I also walked in a stream.
I followed men.
That's what happened to me.
Yeah, did your little kid?
work out well for you okay is there a resurrection point for
you there is there is oh my god oh my god crash that was
awful i thought so too oh my god okay yippee it is porn
again oh my god man you know for for everything that i'm
really glad that live who carries us you know why doesn't i
just take don't get Get that shot.
Don't get it.
Do not get hit by that.
What do we get?
I got hit by hit.
Wait, there's still the forbidden one.
There's the forbidden one.
You're too far away.
Hold on.
We gotta replicate one of the, we gotta replicate the
mushroom.
I have, I have enough to replicate it or the sausage.
We gotta replicate one of them.
Oh, I lost that thing because I died.
Oh, yeah.
I forgot it was you.
Okay.
Should we open that?
Is it worth opening?
Potentially.
We're kind of looking rough right now.
What is it?
Oh, I'll open it.
Ouch.
What's in it?
I got a scout effigy.
Sweet.
I don't remember what that does.
What does it do?
I think we might...
The arrow from your body.
Give me the scout effigy.
What's the...
What's it do?
Put it in Limo's backpack.
What does it do?
No.
Put it in Limo's backpack.
I don't know what it is.
I don't know what it does.
I don't know.
I want her to have it just.
Oh, it's a revive.
It's a revive.
Put it in Lama's backpack.
Oh, okay, okay.
She's so cryptic about items for Conservation.
Oh, everything.
I don't know what it does.
I said, put it in her backpack so whatever happens, she can
save us with whatever item that was.
We didn't know if it would save us.
I had to look at chat.
I looked at chat to see what it was.
Who shot me with an arrow, by the way?
What is the secretive milk do?
This place...
It's very different.
Yeah, it's the Citadel.
Okay, do not touch the shiny things.
Do not...
Okay, there's not here yet.
We do the stairs.
All right.
Shiny things.
It's not there yet.
You don't know what it is.
Just keep Lime alive.
Our mission is to keep Lime alive.
It's not beautiful.
I need a heal if we find one, not urgently, but a little
bit.
Me too.
What's this?
All right.
Oh, my God.
I'm going upstairs.
Get that to Lime.
She can stab us for stamina.
She can stab us.
for salmon we are no pressure or anything we are the cattle
fodder for you you can stab us all right i've never been in
here so i don't know if i can find this um oh look at that
guy oh my god i've been here before so but it's very rough
this is very rough i've played these games
Look, I'm gonna just go and outdoor.
donut is ready to hand?
Oh.
Okay?
Oh, I'm good.
I'm good.
I don't think this is...
I just kinda started going up.
I didn't, I didn't know this was the location.
I don't think this is where you're gonna get up top, but
it's gonna be a lot of stamina.
You're gonna use a bunch of stamina getting up there.
No, I'm fine.
I'm fine.
It doesn't take up all of it.
Can I get a hand up?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm scouting.
We should get the dagger to stuff- uh, to Limo's so she can
use it to stab us.
for more stamina only if she stops you thanks i don't have
enough room right now um i've got room i think here right uh
oh my god there's like a giant bloody bludgeoning ball yeah
it does ricochet i feel like what's that like mysterious
fire cube thing yeah what's the mysterious fire cube what's
that thing what are you looking at oh it's nothing it's just
decoration There's actually nothing.
Is that a good route, Zamb?
It's gonna be rough on stamina unless you got extra.
Okay, I can give hands.
I can give hands.
There you go.
You're fine.
I can give.
I can give hands.
You look for the next route, Labo.
Oh, I got it.
You look for the next way.
You are the king.
Oh, Christ.
I don't like that.
Uh, do we climb along the outside of this?
side is a bunch of like swirling you can you can um bounce
between the two basically it doesn't yeah you don't have to
you can go in and out okay it's also there's a big gap like
we can walk around it honestly this is we could go up here
it's kind of claustrophobic like we could do what should we
climb this i'm gonna go i'm gonna go get the treasure chest
oh jesus snuffy full guys oh did she get I got a candle, but
does that even do anything at this point?
No, it doesn't.
There's nothing in here that requires a candle.
I don't like that noise.
If you crouch, just crouch.
And then you...
Yep, going.
You good, Snuffy?
I'm coming.
I think I'm going the right way.
Oh, shoot.
Does that require enough stamina?
Yep, yep, yep, yep.
Help.
Thank you.
Okay, don't touch.
these because that just takes away your stamina okay
permanently we could climb along this bit then yeah and then
up to here that's a good climb yeah yeah careful there's an
arrow well the arrow just there's all the staircases we
could go if we can get back to the outside yeah yeah we can
get back out that would good um we could go here oh no i've
seen this before i don't know how to get you out of there oh
no what she's in the floor she's in the floor i don't know
how to fix that okay for me she's okay for me if she's okay
for you then let's just hope she's fine now she's fine now
okay she's not for me should we go around to the outside
because i don't know what to go Maybe like here.
Actually, we could go here and then climb...
Oh, we just...
No, we can't go up there.
There's actually a decent looking spot here.
Do you see it?
Yeah, I see it.
If we go back down to here.
I think we should have gone back down to the outer wall.
I mean, we could look at the outer wall.
Yeah, like, do we go out here?
We could try.
Just look.
Like here?
See the routes.
Don't touch it.
There is, we go here and then here and then here and here,
that's why works oh i'm not going i'm here is there a route
there live kind of i think the other way would have been
better i don't know i was thinking like oh wait stuffy is
there a route there um i was gonna go like up here maybe i
don't know if this is possible actually this might be way
time was there a route back there there's a couple come have
a look All right, Stuffy, we're separating.
Stuffy has a dagger.
I just remembered.
There's a couple here.
You see this, this, all of these?
I don't know.
What do we do from here?
That's the thing.
Here, maybe?
It's coming fast, you guys.
It's coming real fast.
It's coming.
Yeah.
I feel like...
Why did you guys get over there?
We jump from here to...
Oh.
I think this might work.
Hold on.
Here?
Does it work?
And then to here.
I don't know if there's a way after that though.
We have a couple of items that we can use.
Oh no, don't step on that.
Don't step on this.
Help!
Got you.
I'm gonna move up.
left side this is that goes my extra stamina thank you got
you i'm gonna move up the kids there's not much space thank
you all right got you there's another i'm like so dry of
mouth right now i like i forgot to breathe all right someone
was getting that only one person should try it there is a
route here you can wait for it and then we go up back out
yeah there's a anything good Oh, can you throw it over?
I can also the jetpack.
I don't think I can pick it up unless I don't have to do it
in my back.
Oh, okay, wow.
Oh, like, yeah, you have to drop the fanny pack.
No, no, I got it.
I got it.
All right.
Okay.
This is ominous.
I don't like this.
I'm one of the jets.
All right, well, here we go.
Well, you should have went for it.
Yeah, I should have.
But I didn't.
I was a fool.
You were a fool.
hey oh i need help thank you the thing is the jetpack it's
sometimes you can accidentally use it because it's just
space bar i saw you use it at the end there yeah that's the
thing using it thank you help me please help me please got
you i'm almost out of stamina like for real i believe in you
hungry yeah i found one food item oh no it's okay probably
um i'm gonna jump Looks good.
I figure out the route now.
Maybe here?
Yeah.
There's a ladder as well.
Apparently you climb fast.
And then...
Yeah, either use that or use this ladder and go to here.
I don't know how fast the boost is.
How much...
Is it good, Snuffy?
Or are you gonna run out?
I think you like...
As soon as you let go and use a huge chunk of stamina.
I can go up, use my jetpack, and then pull a rope down.
Sure.
Sounds good.
okay yeah all right i've got extra rope i think so we should
be right yeah i can give me the rope in my bag all right
let's see if this works oh chad also says you can stop at
the top of the ladder and wait oh okay yeah yeah we can just
do that oh guys guys guys look good guys guys let's come oh
oh guys okay it's coming it's coming oh crud should
we just start climbing okay let me let me know when I have
to put it that's good that's good all right I didn't trust I
just climbed just in case this looks fine this looks good
yeah you guys good are you guys good because we gotta keep
climbing oh help There we go.
I'm out of here.
Yeah, I feel like it's past the end.
I know.
I forget every time.
Suitcase.
Um, I have a granola bar.
Give that to Mint.
She's really hungry.
Granola bar feeds?
I don't think granola bar feeds.
It's just energy, doesn't it?
I think it's food.
It's nutritious.
Wait, okay.
I'm just gonna climb over to you and then give it to you
later.
Yeah.
Oh, there's a trap there.
Be careful.
I got you.
you uh if you want to go to here we have to go a little bit
up because of the trap i think here you go oh go high oh
yeah it did help a lot actually all right your turn oh the
gloom is so close uh this looks oh there was a can you get
the arrow off of me it's on my leg oh i got it i got it okay
uh one directly above here i see it okay
I have to use my jetpack.
No, no more jetpack.
I need a hand.
Thank you.
Got you.
We got you.
I don't have jetpack anymore.
There's...
We can go around and get these steps.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
I'm so...
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna be so sweaty, guys.
Can you make it?
I think you might have to kill me.
Just about.
What?
Oh, wait.
I don't think I'm gonna make it.
I think okay, you I've got a hand though kill me no kill me
I have no killing on me kill.
Okay kill me.
We don't have to die.
It's a little bit premature.
I'm not gonna make it.
I'm not gonna make it No, we can make it.
We can make it Just start high There there We lose mince
body.
I swear to god if we lose mince we need the cattle The
cattle we're all cattle does not the lihmo She's calling me
a heifer.
You gotta be like confident.
We're all gonna get there.
It's gonna be great.
Do we use the staircase again?
Stay on the middle or go with the outside?
Wait, how did you get there?
I think the middle.
The middle?
Oh, okay, okay.
I didn't know it was in this way, this way, this way.
This is good.
No, where you were?
We were just jumping.
And then we go up here?
Yeah, yeah, just jump.
Although, where do we go for once we get here?
Up here?
Yeah, to avoid the trap again.
Yeah.
We have to.
There's no other way.
hurry hurry here i come oh thanks i don't need a hand thank
you good okay oh wait there's traps there there's something
like oh oh wait we can't go to the right either yeah yeah
that's what i'm saying there's nothing we could do i need a
hand snuffy i need a hand thank you oh lord i'm actually You
might just have to take a trap.
I have to.
You actually have to stab me.
You have to stab me.
There's no...
I'm performing surgery.
Ow!
Stuffy, you have to stab me.
I have no more...
I went through the arrow.
I have no more stamina.
You have to stab me.
There's no reason.
What?
I actually have no more stabs.
Just stab me.
Take me out.
It's over.
Just take me out.
Why isn't it working?
I mean...
I'm a kid.
Why isn't it working?
Oh my gosh.
Because I've already stabbed me already.
I think I stabbed her then.
oh never mind oh all right all right all right oh wait you
can revive me with the effigy later when i move oh yeah can
i revive you now no no don't revive me now let me just eat
my food
which way did we go over here you're gonna get stabbed
though oh god my sacrifice will not be you don't get stabbed
when you uh oh whoops stab when someone grabs you it's nice
nice okay so there's an inside again is there anywhere on
the outside to go it's gonna look could go here this looks
kind of nice all right I'm a hero oh my god I'm a hero
getting real comfortable getting Can you help?
Yes.
I am a hero.
You good?
I'm eating.
I just go up here then if you're fine.
I don't know.
Let me check these stairs.
I'm enjoying the afterlife.
We don't have the duplication.
Yeah, I know.
It's nice, right?
Okay.
I think just up here again?
Or actually no, yeah.
You guys should have followed you.
Yeah, yeah.
Come across.
I'll give you a hand.
where is me at the top or if you need more cattle i couldn't
use a hand over here what was that don't you it's like you
just exploded i almost dropped my drink oh there we go
that's funky that's real funky i can't like lift you guys up
okay um there's a few different places maybe like this is
not very i think can we go this way all right you guys need
a ghost to scout these yeah that looks better i keep
thinking these doorways are like or these windows are
doorways lots of places to die over here we could
alternatively go around and see if there's a better place
all the way over here because this is we're gonna get like
shot there's not much time left there's not much time you
guys have to come into the path okay i think you'll have to
come into the arrow at this point okay if anything you could
rise me against stab me if you guys you'll really want to
feel adventurous climb on the cliff and you won't get hit by
the arrow thank you yeah go down if you can there we go cool
anything in here there's like a ladder right there's the
ladder yeah let's use the ladder villa pressure planes oh oh
but yeah these look like they'll stab you be careful yeah no
they are they will they will oh my god the fog is so close
they will we need to just go decision i'm going i believe
Oh, it's pretty it takes a lot of stamina Gotta get to the
oh There's a stopping point and there is a stopping point
you should use the stopping point and then regain your
stamina before you do the climb Yeah, it's not be lost.
Yeah, oh my god.
Oh, it's so close.
I'm going Thank you.
Oh, no, Gabe.
I'm trapped.
I'm good.
I'm good I'll try better inside you go up and then you go
outside at the that next point you see that next one where
stuffy is just outside you want to go outside yeah and then
you go out i don't know i don't know what shroud is there i
think i'm to here and then like a baby i don't know i think
like inside right might be easier i'm climbing okay just
don't touch the ice if you can't i touch the ice well you
have to commit Then...
Commit, crouch and go to the left.
That's terrible.
Crouch and go to the left.
Crouch and get to commit.
Yet to commit.
And go to the left.
Yeah.
And then...
Go to the left side.
Get all these traps!
Help!
Oh!
I'm okay.
I really need to heal.
Jesus Christ.
I don't...
Well, the only way to heal is to stab.
Yeah.
I'm dead weight.
Keep going.
with you it got used up oh did it no you could use it more
than once yeah you have to just grab the knife you have to
grab the knife off my back oh oh I might have gone the wrong
way hold on okay I think we split up a little bit there is a
bag snuffy can you give me a hand wait where are you oh yeah
okay I'm good I'm good oh fuck this watch out here there's
like two luggage is though I do the time I'm just gonna let
you guys know I'm having a great time eating my curry rice
I'm happy for you I have bandages I have bandages for you I
would love bandages wait there's one more thing in here but
it's like oh this is a flare it's a flare okay can I come
come back this way if you can I am oh yeah you go you Wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait.
Let me move it on here.
Thank you.
Oh, it is a good choice.
Oh, there we go.
It's spicy.
Thank you.
Okay.
I'm going to go.
Okay, which way is nothing?
Oh, you going this way?
I got energy and the thickments too.
Maybe?
Oh, if you want to dump the thickments in my backpack.
Okay.
Oh, sorry.
The energy drink.
I'm in scalp.
I don't know where to go from there, though.
There's a left side.
Let me go.
Oh, shoot.
oh shoot oh shoot shoot i can do the handout if you need it
you need it jump you need a jump you need a jump you need a
job i got you she has no more stamina i don't know if mint
will make it that took all my stamina oh no i didn't make it
man no do i have rope snuffy is it rope in my bag or did do
i have the rope no it's it's gone you see energy you have to
drink the energy drink and then climb oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
drink it and climb just start climbing just start climbing
I'm going.
I'll be using it if you can.
Are you good?
I'm good.
Give her a hand.
I got her hand.
There you go.
Okay.
Um, why am I getting sleepy for?
Um, this looks cold.
This way, this way, this way.
You have to go outside.
It's the only way.
If you have an extra serving, could I have a thick mint?
Yeah.
Oh, mint.
That's the trap.
That'd be great.
We'll do it after this.
This is what's booked.
So you have to go left side and then climb up.
You can climb, technically climb past that, but you have to
go left.
oh that was fucked i hate it when you kind of like readjust
your grip and it just eats your stamina it's great yeah um
it's the only way oh my god this looks fucked have i got you
nice thank you whoa okay crazy yeah could you feed me a meat
if you don't mind yeah thank you mint uh there's this here
are you hungry this here um no not as much probably You're
almost there.
Okay, I got my own out.
You're almost there, guys.
Guys, I see it.
I see it.
Snoopy!
I'm moving on the platform.
There you go.
Snoopy!
No!
Oh, no.
Snoopy!
No!
Wait, wait, wait.
Use it now.
Use the F.
Oh, no.
Use it now.
Is she, did she fall?
Yeah.
Yeah, you have to admit, can you grab the FG out and use it?
Use it?
Uh, which way?
Grab the FG out and use it.
Which way?
Use it.
Is it just gonna revive a random person?
It's just gonna revive a...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
No!
Stop it, you fucking!
Stop it!
I didn't even die yet!
What happened?
I was on the floor!
So I was like, use it!
Just use it so I get to be alive!
How do we even get up?
Oh, you're okay.
Sorry.
You're here.
You're okay.
I don't even know where to go from here.
This sucks.
Oh, yeah.
This would be better, but I don't think we can get around
there.
Um...
You might have to use your... Okay, you have...
I'm going... I'm going this way.
I'm, I don't... You have to use all your energy.
And then you have to drink your sports drink after that.
She makes it with all her energy, by the way.
up here that's what i was thinking there's a little ledge
there's a little ledge yeah yeah
oh i didn't realize that was a stabby platform we're no
there is one oh no you have to go here you have to go there
you have to go go go go too
late okay so um and maybe you should not have used the
effigy there maybe you could have i don't know maybe okay
yeah yeah yeah that's good that's good that's good go up go
up and the left side yeah yep and then go up you're there
you're literally there you go up go up and then you're there
you're literally there there's a staircase and take you up
there we're here you're ready you're there you're there i
need it wait a minute you can die you can die it's oh she
said i didn't have to tell her to die oh you could die by
the way stuffy she made it oh wait you live you're gonna
live what did you climb Go Snuffy, go!
I moved it.
You're gonna make it!
No way!
We were so glad!
I know the world!
My sacrifice was not in vain!
I knew it!
We did it!
It's not in vain.
We climbed for 12 days!
Well, we actually won!
We did!
We were gonna make it!
There were so many moments where we should not have even
made it.
There were so many moments.
I can't believe it.
I wanted you to use the epitome before she fully dives
because I know the epitome.
for the last person that dies.
Fully dies.
Like, just use it.
Just use it before she fully dies.
I thought you said you didn't know how to use it.
Oh.
Of course she's lying.
Nothing.
How do you lie?
Well, that's your karma, Doki Bird.
It's true.
Are you good?
What do you mean?
I helped you win, Stuffy.
I helped you get to the top.
Only because I'm not- What on earth is going on with these
players?
What are these?
What is happening?
They're freaking out, man.
Peter Parker and Bucky lives.
Captain America and Iron Man dies.
It's true!
It's just like the movie!
It's just like the movies!
Captain America and Iron Man's gone!
I can't see the rope!
I threw my smoke!
I can't see it!
Oh my god, it's in front of you!
Stop it!
Don't die!
Don't die after everything!
Stop it!
Grab the rope!
Did she grab it?
I don't know.
She did, she did, she grabbed it!
Yay!
For game pros, so I got so scared.
The way the line moves character looks over at the two MDCs.
Oh my gosh!
I died for it!
Oh my god!
Oh, I get a silly face.
That was so good.
We did it!
Success!
Triumph!
I sacrificed my soul for the cause.
My death was not in vain.
Look at how much smoke we put on the thing.
Oh my god, you're gonna burn down the mountain.
And now we can finally do our announcement.
Oh yeah!
Imagine!
Yay!
And then there's our danceman right there.
Imagine, guys.
I'm gonna get to eat food, guys.
It's like ice.
We did it.
We made it, guys.
We fucking made it.
We made it.
We did.
So proud.
100% success for us, the Soppy Sisters.
First try.
True, true, true.
Awesome, Gina Colab merch.
Guys, remember, the Cheetah merch to celebrate.
Link the YouTube video.
Buy our merch and you too can be as united as us.
I need to go find the YouTube link.
As everyone knows, the Sloppy Sisters are all about teamwork
and friendship.
I'm buying them.
We were the whole time.
No betrayal.
Or any sort of drama.
There was no moment in which we suddenly ended up in two
separate lobbies out of sheer stubbornness.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
By buying our collab merch, you can have a very cooperative
time like us where we're working together.
True friendship.
It represents true friendship.
Yeah.
We got it done.
Even if it's the sloppiest.
Even if it's the sloppiest, we still make it to the end.
We made it.
I'm so proud of us.
Yeah, put your hands in.
Put your hands in.
Yeah, it's Duffy.
It's Duffy.
Oh my gosh.
I haven't played this game in so long.
That was so much fun, though.
That was awesome.
Yeah.
It was very, very good.
I thought we were dead.
Like, I legitimately thought I was dead.
I thought Duffy was dead many, many times.
No, you can't see this.
I thought after everything, we might have finally broken the
curse of like, but at least we have Lyme to carry us.
But unfortunately, no.
Another day, another Lyme move.
75 99 of the sloppy sisters right there let's go we made it
though we made it i'm happy for all of the baby joey's yeah
we're like in line was the possum and we're all on the back
oh that's so cute that's adorable some fan art of that
artists get on that again we're little possums on the back I
was kidding.
They were like, oh, I'm going to help us.
We're dead.
I've fallen.
I can't get up.
I don't know how you survived.
That was like four hours long.
You're so strong.
I'm so tired.
See, I told you, the more sleep deprived you are, the more
locked in you'll be.
I knew it.
I knew the stress.
It's true.
The fear of having to redo it.
Let me let me get through that.
Wait, wait, wait.
Wait, before...
Oh, we got...
We got...
Got linked the merch and everything, guys.
I linked it.
I've linked it.
I've linked my chat.
Pinned message in my chat.
Pinned message.
Yeah, pin comment.
Pin comment.
Go check out the merchandise.
It looks amazing.
September 25th.
The Sloppy's University.
We could be the sloppy as us.
Peace.
In a good way.
I'm gonna check out the merch guys and then and then buy all
of it buy every one of it buy the entire collection every
single thing hell yeah you guys have to be Thanos and yeah
make your own sloppy sisters group too who will be Captain
America our men Bucky and Peter Parker we need sloppy sister
action figures now yeah you have those sloppy sisters will
return on doomsday adventures swapping sisters will return
yeah it's so cute oh my gosh thank you very much you guys
i'm gonna go and kiss my dogs and go to bed yeah look guys
i'm so excited thank you everybody
good night everyone thank you for climbing with me goodbye
Sloppy!
I love you guys!
Good night!
We did it guys!
The Sloppy sisters I'm gonna say it would have been so much
it would have been cool if we made it to the very end and be
like now it's midnight!
But we also, we didn't know we were gonna make it to the end
honestly.
We We had no clue if we were gonna make it to the end.
Oh yeah.
See you guys, the snappy sister pure teamwork, cooperation,
no arguments, no backstabbing, no la- oh my gosh, wait, let
me get- let me get the renders better.
Hi.
Ah, there we go.
Is that what it's supposed to look like?
I don't think that's what it's supposed to look like.
No, no backstabbing, no, um, no divorce arc, no civil war,
all teamwork, all cooperation, all communicating together,
clear comms, uh, that's, that's the sloppy sister motto.
That's the sloppy sister way, guys.
look at that when we work together to achieve a goal because
in the end in the end we are a team and friendship is magic
the sloppy way but yeah I'm so excited that the collab was
finally announced it's been the my apologies it was it was
I'll take the blame it was it was my fault that the collab
got postponed a lot because I was like I just wanted like
something unique for you guys and like it was so hard
because i feel like my design was like had like elements of
everybody else's colors too so i wanted a very i wanted like
you know when each person you know if there's like your own
group your own friend group has you know an ibu uh a creator
and uh what's limus thing the limu fan
what was uh what was limus what was Lymo's I kept looking at
it for so long it's just this Lymo ferret I it just says
Lymo okay a Lymo ferret fans of Lymo or dragon yeah I I
wanted like if your friend group has one of each you know we
wanted like match up together going to convention I wanted
it to be like each person is different in their own way I
know I should what I know I have thought about it like oh
what if I should went in full yellow but i was like but i
felt like i worked i don't want like all your closet to just
be yellow you know i don't want your entire class to just be
yellow because uh because like you know our last collab was
also yellow so now it's just like oh i want to make sure uh
that yeah we all have our own frat house oh i should have
said that it's like we all have our own frat houses our own
fraternity our own sorority you know the jokey fraternity oh
that's good wait that's good why did you guys say that
earlier fraternity was so good
yeah um yeah so i was like i was like thinking really hard
being like uh i don't i don't i want i want like something
different every time so your closet isn't just all yellow
you know um yeah the sloppy sister for your dad that was
basically a haste oh my god that's so good i should have
stolen your ideas and pretend it was my content i oh my god
i'm writing this down i'm writing this down i'm right let me
write this down
the sloppy sister's fraternity well mine will be a
fraternity as your yeah so I don't know just because like I
maybe next time maybe next time we'll do another apparel of
yellow in it but for this one I decided and also like I feel
like um a lot of people like working wearing darker jackets
too like I like working wearing darker jackets in general um
I don't so I was just like oh so it was like a lot back and
forth with you know I felt really bad because like I was the
last person to finalize my I was the last person to finalize
the merch forever like for my my sample like my um my
apparel so I felt really bad that I like delayed it a lot
I'm really sorry guys I'm sorry I just I just really wanted
something that you guys would all want as dragons I really
do so I do hope you guys enjoy the merch collab Gina worked
really really really hard and she has the patience of an
angel like I would have yelled I would have don't you i i
give you permission to yell at me i'm sorry i i give you
permission to yell at me gina i'm so sorry yeah um and i'm
yeah so i really appreciate i was just like but gina what
have i changed this at like last minute i'm sorry i'm so
sorry but yeah i do hope you guys like the collection um
remember when we pitched it we were like hesitant about like
if we do like a like because we're not really like you know
it was like last year so we weren't like we don't have a lot
of collapse together yeah at sloppy sisters we're just
getting started as sloppy sisters i'm glad we're able to do
something official and i think the sloppy university thing
was such a cute idea uh was such a cute idea and i thought
was really creative and i love the whole aesthetic of
everything so yeah um get a get yourself a sloppy group get
yourself a sloppy group and have you know get a eyeball a
lemon a curator and a dragon together and be your own sloppy
group too yeah each rep rep in your repping your oshi or or
form a dragon fraternity yeah
Yeah, that's right.
We travel in packs.
We get We all wear we all wear varsity jacket.
That's right.
Dragon Dragon
That's right like you know like this fraternity cause like I
don't know Delta five Dragon five What was it?
Sigma Delta.
Sigma Dragons.
Dragon.
Dragon 5.
Dragon, dragon.
Ra, ra, ra.
Dragon.
Yeah.
Yeah, we got our own frat now.
Be top of the class.
That's right.
I'm a boo-goon.
You gotta pick one!
Cut the jackets and half and sew them together to rep both
sides.
Dragon 5!
Hoorah!
Bro, yeah, bro.
Yeah, you wanna join our frat?
Oh, you gotta be in the, you gotta go to the basement for
the hazing ceremony.
Yeah.
Dude, yeah, that's what, that's why I wanted, I really
wanted, like, I actually sort of wanted, like, a frat
energy, like a frat energy with my apparel too, I'm sad.
get done like uh men was very feminine i was like hurrah
dragon hurrah and then men was like more feminine or hers
yeah but yeah i'm glad you guys enjoyed the collab it was
really fun uh it took us a while to set everything up so i'm
glad you guys like it let me see if i have anything i wanted
i was debating i wanted to show And yes, she was the only
one who got the female mod.
That's true.
That's funny.
The mod was really cute, though.
Let me see if I have anything else I can show.
I was showing it really, really fast.
But, yeah, there was, like, so many concepts.
I don't mind showing concepts because I like showing, like,
the design process.
And maybe, you know, in the future, we could, like, do
something like with Gina again in the future for something
similar.
Obviously, not, like, exactly the same, but, like, maybe the
color scheme.
or something um oh my god the pictures are so big i mean
like that guy from an inside job show where he's in 50 frats
and was hazed by every single one thank you super chat meddy
thank you thank you ah i should have brought up the
fraternity like which frat are you guys gonna join huh
yeah this is one of them i think that it was really hard to
use the color because snuffie's wall is also blue and that's
also the thing like you know let me like choose the color
palette and everything and the delta omega cap a lot of
fraternity thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
delta omega dragon fraternity reporting in thank you thank
you thank you um but yeah like the bags too i was just like
oh i don't want to be all blue so you want a black because
it's like i think black and yellow black and yellow black
and yellow is a very nice color combination too so this is
like the other bag concept we have here and then And I think
we, I really liked this one, but I don't think we could do
it because it's like knit it.
So I feel like it would be really, I wish we could have had
yellow and white.
But I think like because of logistic wise, it's like a cute
concept, but it's hard to get it done in general.
Because it's like yellow and white versus in knitting.
I get why like we went with all yellow instead.
And then, I guess this was the old cardigan this side.
Apparently, no one in the council voted for it.
So I went with the all yellow.
And these are all concept arts for mine.
And this was some of the original concepts.
I'll show like mine.
So like I said, I didn't go with the all yellow.
I did it for a while because I felt like, oh, it's just too
much yellow, you know?
So that's why I didn't go with yellow, because I felt like,
oh, I already have, I already released yellow merch.
I don't want it to be all yellow, because I already had
yellow merch as well.
So then I was just like, ah, and then the, and then the, the
blue was more minty color, and everything.
And so it was like, If so and I didn't go with a blue jacket
only because The reason why I didn't go with blue jacket
because it was too similar of a blue to snuffie's jacket too
So let's see Because if I went with the blue jacket it would
the colors would have been too similar
So here are like all the other so this was the original some
of the original designs where we finalized It's like I'm
paying that one day when I see the mint and yellow color
jacket design to thank you
I don't know it depends on what the future holds um and what
else uh I really like the hat the hat's super cute so you
guys can see originally it was more cat like for me but then
we changed it to I asked to change it to a beak only because
I felt like everyone had like some characteristics that's
similar to like their animal form and I was just like well
it would make sense if I was if I was it was a bird beak
because it was dokey bird not dokey so so that's why I liked
how the hat is sort of like kindergarten-ish like but like
how we play off each other so we're like we're in
kindergarten and be like no I'm gonna tell on you I'm gonna
tell you on your lime moon I'm gonna tell lime moon what you
did and
yeah yeah out of the hats really really cute and then uh
let's see it and then we have the the models modeling the
varsity jacket and and the outfits again half for school
jacket for college t-shirt for work true and there's the
cardigan and then yeah the our ikime man model and then
mince cute model or her stuff and then what else i show
every i think i showed yeah this was the i showed everything
did i oh yeah and then here's our bad concepts too there
were like several bad concepts for colors because it was
like between yellow and blue and i thought yellow look the
yellow black was just i like the i like the yellow black
concept more know i just feel like you popped out a lot yeah
yeah and then it has the little it was very subtle too so
it's like not very obviously like vtuber themed and
everything yeah so this is the full my full catalog the
jacket the bag the cardigan you tell like the original
cardigan the chibi originally was the original sweater and
then what it could have been yeah
Yeah.
And that's everything.
Please check out the collab, guys.
Check it on pre-order.
Let me link the...
Check it out, guys.
A lot of hot work went into it.
I'm really happy that we have an official merch line, too.
It's really, really cute.
Yeah, it's really fun.
Thank you, everybody, for commenting.
guys I really appreciate it everyone we guys have fun time
hanging out with the sloppy sisters as always I always have
fun collabing with the sloppy sisters there's always been a
fun time you don't you'll never expect what happens with
with us you never know what's gonna happen the sloppy
sisters collab that's for sure it was a very fun stream I
had a great time um I guess I'll show you guys before i go
i'll show you guys the last two the videos again and make
sure to um check out make sure to give a like and a comment
on the on the actual video release too because it helps a
lot all right let me show you guys i'll show you the mod the
one that you know the one that mint accidentally played let
me show you the video that mint accidentally played instead
of the actual video um where is it where's my media source
media source where are you is it this one and that's the
media source is that my correct media okay I put it in the
sponsor video area this is the montage this is the one where
she she accidentally played the first time we thought we our
house was pretty sloppy we wouldn't have it any other way
Oh, the long count that just to play the wrong video.
We wouldn't have it any other way.
Yeah.
Who else but the sloppies?
Truly sloppy style.
And this was the video we were supposed to play.
Such
a cute...
video
pre-order now pre-order now wait actually I showed this part
let me double check also need to make the tweet too later I
didn't talk about the emblems too let me see it's so weird
being able to like I did not realize but I did not realize I
was like partially blind the entire time for more than for
almost a year is that I like didn't realize how I'm I don't
know I just was not paying attention and I looked at my
glasses lens I was like oh that's a really bad scratch in
the middle of my eye like in the middle of my glass lens eye
I was like wait that's actually pretty bad I like I finally
looked at it I was like huh it's not a it's not coming off
and i was like you know what okay to be fair i didn't notice
it for a while for like maybe a couple months ago but then i
was just like ah and i put it on it was like it's not that
bad i feel like it's because my brain was so accustomed to
looking at it um no i do clean it i noticed it for a couple
of months but i was like well i was i was just like oh i
think my brain was so accustomed to it that it like deleted
that part in my brain so it doesn't it wasn't noticeable and
then today i was just like you know what let me try words my
last pair of glasses and just compare because i was at that
one point i was just like you know what let's let me let me
try it because i was just like i feel like it's not good for
me to wear this glasses with the scratches and i wore it and
i was just like oh hey wait this is a lot clearer
i was like That is a lot clearer.
And then I tried to wear the other, and I wore the other
pants, like, oh, now I see the scratch.
Because my brain was like, wait a minute, there was a
scratch here.
Then my brain realized, wait, I can live life without the
scratch.
And then I wore my other glasses again.
And I was just like, oh, wait a minute.
Oh, I see the scratch now.
I,
wait.
I see it now and I was like oh huh maybe I shouldn't have
just lived with it maybe maybe I maybe I shouldn't have just
lived with that maybe I should have got that repaired sooner
um but hey I fixed it well technically I just well not
really fixed it but you you understand guys you guys get it
oh yeah i wanted to show oh my gosh whoops i want to show
the other emblems because it was like there were other
emblems at first that we did like the original design that
wasn't because i was like oh we should have the tomato and
the trophy like the oshim right where's the original oh i'm
trying to find is this one no that was also the tomato and
the bullet what was the original that we this oh it was this
This was the original emblem.
So it was my birthday.
And my Oshimark.
And there was like dry wounds for life.
Stuff like that.
But then I was just like.
Oh let's just put the tomato in there.
I feel like.
I feel like you know.
It would be funnier.
It's more dokey weird.
It was a tomato.
Anyway.
Anyway that's everything.
Thank you for whatever comment.
As always everybody.
Say hi.
Join the posture check.
Get up and move around.
And get that blood flowing.
And you say it for me.
At the bed.
cause you deserve it you're the dance yeah wow all right
guys i'll see you guys later everybody bye guys bye